No,
you don't look very fat to me.
Describe.
I wouldn't say that's a fat guy.
It feels good.
You would definitely say stocky.
I wouldn't say you're fat either.
Right now.
I wouldn't say you're a fat guy.
I know you're wearing layers right now.
I'm wearing layers.
You're weighing in so you're trying to
dehydrate.
Yeah,
because you.
You kind of came in late to the game.
He sandbagged me.
This butterfly since August and
November.
He says,
Hey,
let's do a weight loss challenge to 40
to 56 at the time.
I'm like,
okay,
that's a little bit of a Bert Ism
though.
Bert.
I don't know if you know his birth prone
to exaggerate slightly.
It's called hyperbole.
He was 2:56 on Thanksgiving after a full
binge.
That wasn't his walk.
It was a bit.
It was a New York binge where I drank
everyday on opiod radio drink every
single night and then came back and he
weighed himself and then I like.
I was a full binge already said to me.
He's like,
there's nowhere to 44.
I got on because that's what bonds was
on November 11th.
That's where my special and showtime
came out and that's what we weighed in
the car.
It was the day I show you the next day
at the end of the world podcast.
Right.
What did you think?
I wasn't eighth though.
I didn't.
I didn't check.
I was robust.
You were pigs.
That was big.
That a gut.
Now why?
What made you guys start this story,
but actually that's already made the
challenge,
but I was thinking about the origin of
bird is fat because you get the other
dicks.
Hashtag your mom's house.
Here's an example.
The other kids,
when you did like them,
that's where I was at your mom's house.
You wonder where this hate filled
fucking podcast comes from a is where it
came from
watching a movie.
Do you remember a few years ago the head
of the International Monetary Fund,
Dominique Strauss Kahn was the scandal.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yes,
that's right.
He was accused of raping the eventually
cleared and inspired a movie that I
think was on hbo or showtime and we were
watching it and they did it like loosely
or mostly based on that story,
but it wasn't a biopic and the guy that
played dsk was Gerard Depardieu and
there's a scene where they have him get
arrested and do the perp walk and then
they do the strip search like at rikers
island and he had this totally bloated,
distended,
like big boobs body and we were like,
that looks like burt,
but like,
but bigger,
like way bigger.
So then we talked about it on our
podcast and then people started to
photoshop burt onto.
I did not get.
I was actually taking it as compliments
because I know he's very talented actor.
I was like,
oh,
that's cool.
Okay,
this is all blindsided me.
This is happening in their little
fucking world where they're just.
And then at the same time I started to
Vlog.
Remember when I did my blog,
Jamie and I and I knew that one of the
things was popular.
Blogs was weight loss.
So I was car care,
like watching my weight loss and I was
losing weight,
but I was always weighing in in a speedo
and it was very self deprecating.
I was trying to make it funny.
These two are watching at this at the
exact same time and making fun of how
fat I am.
I'm oblivious to this,
I'm oblivious to all of this.
And then one day Doug Benson and I get
into a fight.
I remember,
I think everyone knows what I'm talking
about here.
Yeah.
That was,
uh,
on his podcast,
right?
There was a live podcast.
It was very uncomfortable and it was
bad.
And I think I spoke to.
I called Tom.
I went right to the bar after it.
I was fucking worked up.
I was like,
I think I called him.
I was drunk and I go,
I go,
whoa.
He goes,
hello?
I go,
hey,
we need to talk.
And he goes,
I'm so sorry.
I go for what?
And he goes,
wait,
what are you calling yourself?
I go,
Doug and I had a blow out.
He goes,
oh,
nevermind.
Then
wait,
what are you sorry about?
And he's like,
you haven't been online,
have you?
And I said,
no.
And he goes,
all right,
let's talk about what you're upset
about.
And then after we're done,
go online and I just want you to know
Christina and I are very sorry I will
make this stop.
And so I go online.
It is trending,
bird is fat and it's.
And by the way,
and this is the very beginning of it and
I have to be very clear and honest about
all of this emotion because there are
parts of this that are like trigger
warning.
But like it was funny as fucking shit in
it.
You couldn't get mad at it because it
was all their best fans making hilarious
fucking jokes.
One Guy had took the name burnt Chrysler
and made a wet his own fucking profile
for it.
And we made a website.
He registered a website,
by the way,
I saw him in Hartford.
He's obese,
he's obese,
enormous.
And he just sat in the front row the
whole time going burt's fat burns fat.
Next day his mom shows up,
hey buddy,
your mom's morbidly obese.
And the first word she asked me is why
you so fat burt?
She has five bills.
And she said,
why you so fat?
Burton?
I'm like,
Oh my God,
this is getting out of fucking control.
So he heckled you not,
not Hagel.
He was being funny as I hit the stage
to.
Yeah,
like as I walk on stage half guys goes
Wiseberg fat,
like they yell at.
Ari and I went were in Calgary,
stampede.
And when I got on stage,
all they were yelling is birds,
fat burns fat.
Why you so fat white?
And red is like already said,
two things mean that night.
He's like,
I've never seen that.
And then at the end I was like,
I'm not telling the machine.
And they started booing and are just
like,
dude,
you got to tell the machine every
fucking time.
I was like,
yeah,
no shit.
I,
this,
my career has gotten out of fucking
control.
I have no control.
I'm fat and I got to tell the fucking
machine.
And so then then,
then here's the crushing story.
If you don't know,
it's a crazy story that go to the go to
the one that's on facebook that went
viral over the weekend.
Yeah,
12 million views over the weekend that
the machine story.
I told her special.
Our special health goes over the weekend
on facebook and shit.
I was telling Tom Marketing companies
were calling going like,
Hey,
was your secret?
Yeah.
How did you strategize this?
I put up a good story.
It was Fox and like 10 people that are
popular online retweeted it.
So what's really cool about the little
sidebar from this,
but real,
what's really cool about this,
which I think you'll get a kick out of
Joe,
is you guys heard me tell that story for
years ago on this podcast.
I think half the people everyone likes
to have.
People thought it was a lie.
Know other people go,
I don't give a fuck.
Some people are like,
I bet it is true.
The reason it went viral,
I think is that people in my class
tagged in the comment section.
This story is 100 percent true and
posted pictures of the entire trip
through the comment section so you can
see what Igor looks like.
You can see what Sasha looks,
you see the whole,
you see us that night on a train,
drunk as fuck with the two gangsters.
All those were in the comments section
and so everyone that's ever heard the
story lost their shit.
Like,
dude,
I got messages.
Like one guy was said he was cancer and
this is the best thing that's ever
happened with terminal illnesses hooked
up to deal with.
Thank you so much.
And I'm like,
Dude.
But anyway,
that's a sidebar to this where you go to
the facebook,
my facebook page.
Anyway,
one morning I wake up,
now I'm dealing with what is,
what bill burr is,
does references fat shaming and quote
unquote taking on water and I am fat.
And I wake up with panic attack at four
in the morning because I've been
drinking.
And uh,
I go on my,
my wife's friend's instagram and her mom
passed away.
Mom hasn't been hospice.
You know this one,
right?
Oh my God.
So sorry for your loss.
I'm,
we'll see later today and then one tom's
fans and my fat.
I guess rights in the next comment.
So sorry for your loss.
Did burt sit on your mom?
Next is.
Hey,
if you keep her cold,
halitosis
brutal.
Like Brandon and comes over the house.
She had lost her mom,
lost her mom in the middle of the
fucking night and her first words to me
are.
I'm sorry,
what's happening to you online?
Do you remember when you went to the zoo
with the girls?
Want to talk about fucking bizarre.
I actually face time.
Him and I just,
it's a random call middle of the day.
So we answered and he's in public and I
see him while he was like,
hey man.
And I already did.
I said I'm here with.
The girls were talking about the bird is
fat Thomas Shirts.
He's like,
I'm gonna.
Make these shirts.
I'll put them on my website.
We'll split the profits.
Yeah,
just whatever.
Just I'll just tell them on site so we
can split the profits.
We can track and I'm like,
cool,
cool.
I see like his daughter walked by,
so I'm like,
oh,
these people that he's,
you know,
maybe his sister is there with them and
then someone behind them is like,
burt's fat is bad.
And I'm like,
yeah,
like I've figured it's like a friends of
friends,
mother or something.
And then later he's like,
no,
it was right.
Then it was right.
Then I turn the phone around and I go,
I'm talking to Tom Segura right now.
And she goes,
oh,
shut up.
Hi Mommy.
I'm a big fan jeans or whatever the fuck
they say,
but here's the other part that went
crazy buzz after we.
First of all we had,
I did a,
I did press in Syracuse,
I think,
you know,
when you do morning tv and they go,
what do you want us to lead you with?
And it's always like,
you know,
comics will be like asking me about
birds.
I got a great thing,
you know,
and like they want like a bit.
So I was just like asked me why Bert
Kreischer so fat and thinking,
because most of the times they go like,
oh,
I don't know about that,
you know,
they don't want to get racy.
And The lady just goes,
okay,
so
we're just in the middle.
And she was,
oh,
I got to ask you something.
And I go,
what's that?
She goes,
why is Burke Chrysler so fat?
She said it wrong.
And by the way,
Tom doesn't make a joke out of it.
He goes,
well,
he's an alcoholic.
He's got a lot of problems.
And so we play that on the podcast and
we go ask.
The whole thing was asked birth,
why he's so fat.
So why are you so fat?
What I didn't realize,
I thought that like 100 people would
tweet it to him.
I didn't know that they would destroy
his instagram,
facebook,
like troy to the point where I had to
tell my daughters,
you can't read this like it's bad,
but I've never blocked anybody.
But then Joe,
he says this,
there are these people out there that
are fucking broken,
a really hateful things and you're like,
hey man,
I'm all about a good time.
Yeah,
you can make fun of me all you fucking
why ticket?
Like I tweeted some guy today that I
forget what he said.
Oh,
he goes,
to be honest with you,
I think both of you guys are winners in
this challenge.
Congratulations,
by the way,
Bert,
you're still fat.
And I just thought I was on the
treadmill and I stumbled and sort of
laughing and I went,
there's ones like that,
that they're out there that are fucking
great.
There's some funny ones and I also,
I remember I called him when I thought
it was too much.
I go,
I'll do a thing now where I say it.
He's like,
absolutely,
you're not my fucking mother.
Do do that.
Do that.
But coming out the structure of going,
he has asthma.
Stop picking on him.
I was like,
I'll take this on the chin.
But that's when we started to go
competition though.
That's when already stepped in.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Because you know red has no fucking
heart.
Ari who,
who's in Kuala Lumpur right now?
Yeah.
He,
uh,
where he is,
right?
We don't know where he is.
So
he had this podcast and amazing podcast
with Henry rollins.
Henry Rollins,
once a year gets on a plane,
he talks to his travel agent and he
goes,
where can we go?
And she's like,
have you been to Burma?
He's like,
nope.
So he flies to like Burma and knows no
one brings a laptop and a notebook and
some underwear and just fucking wanders
around.
He gets a hotel room and he just goes
out in the street and just goes there
during the day.
And at night he writes,
no,
not oppressed.
I've traveled the fucking world.
Let me tell you something.
Everywhere is the same.
Beaches were beaches,
fucking hotel rooms,
bedrooms hammered everywhere you go.
But I also have an insulary fuzzy Ivan,
insightful fucking eye.
And like,
trust me after,
after a week,
you're like,
okay,
this is getting old.
Is there a four seasons around here?
Like I can't.
I think it gets a thrill of Henry
valance legitimately enjoys it.
If you listen to that podcast that he
did,
it's an amazing podcast because he just
talks about the people that he's met and
all the experiences that he's had.
Maybe Henry rollins a little deeper than
I am.
I am a guy that like,
I want to go to a bar and meet a bunch
of people and hang out and have a good
time.
I'm not like sitting there going,
Whoa,
what is their,
their spice here?
It seems very dominant.
Like I'm not that guy that,
that ice cube way something put it back.
He's just got to suck on an ice cube.
But,
but the only thing I've been doing it.
Let's get these fucking wanes over.
I'm fucking,
we'll get to that.
What kind of timeline are we talking
about that this all started?
So after the Ra podcast,
which was November seventh,
I'm guessing basically that's this year
though.
Yeah,
basically two months.
So this is.
Yeah,
it's basically.
So when,
when did you start losing weight though?
You started losing weight before that?
August.
And what,
what made you decide?
Um,
I think part of it was that we had been
doing all the fat talk like I,
when did the fat talk start with my
assistant started definitely in the
summer.
I remember listening to your podcasts or
it had to be early then it had to be
like may or June.
It was,
it was easily may Miss Syracuse.
Yeah.
Because I remember in July in Alabama
and I was jogging and I was listening to
you,
um,
push fucking destroy me and I could not
stop laughing because it was,
I think it was me talking on phone.
You guys taking everything away.
The funniest thing that I have seen from
this so far is that a lot of English as
a second language teachers around the
country have sent in videos where
they're like in India,
Japan,
China,
and they a lot like an alarming amount
of English to second language.
They put a camera in the room and as
they're teaching the kids,
they teach them to say Burt Chrysler is
fat.
We have tons of these videos where the
kids are like.
And also like one lady was like,
draws like it's just a fat guy on a
chalkboard and she was like,
this is burt and the kids go,
this is burt.
And then she's like,
he eats too much and they're like,
he eats too much.
They go through the whole thing.
See,
he's got a teammate.
I'm doing this fucking Solo.
It's true.
My wife,
my wife got involved.
She fucking hates this weight loss
thing.
Does she?
Oh Hey.
Like I would say that I'm going to
desert me Tom and push you up to go to
dinner and apologize.
What do you call her?
Push.
Because her last name's it.
And when we first met,
always done that.
I'm never good with Christina's and
Tina's and Christians and I'll just call
her push,
push,
push.
I love it.
She's one of my favorite.
Literally my favorite couple of.
I was ever going to be like a,
like a,
a side husband.
I'd be in that couple.
Okay.
I don't think I can react to that.
I don't think I would have had as much
fun doing this with anybody else.
You know?
That's what a lot of people don't
understand is that we're,
we're best friends and so when I did the
podcast with bill and Tom,
people started shitting on Tom and I was
like,
no,
you're blocked now.
I can't if you don't like me,
if you don't like Joey Diaz feeling
like,
or even only joe if you don't like Tom,
I don't like you at all because you
don't get me because these guys are my
friends.
And they'd find my foundation of what I
find funny and what I get.
So like that was one of the things that
got shitty about this is that you'd find
people being like,
fuck Tom's girl.
And you're like,
no,
you're always going to get that right.
Yeah,
yeah.
The people.
Some people got like,
they got the spirit of it wrong,
I think,
you know,
and they were like,
that guy's a fucking piece of shit.
And you're like,
well,
we're like,
we're doing weight loss.
Like fuck.
What's going to.
Probably some of your fucking videos
have been amazing.
I love the video you do.
And when you were playing credence,
let the midnight special.
That is a fucking great video and
drinking a cup of coffee and then you
get on that treadmill.
And then the other one when you're
showing that you did five fucking hours
and 20 minutes on the Treadmill,
you ran 22 fucking miles burned off.
3,000.
How many calories?
Three thousand.
300 calories today.
I did a bet that I made though.
I know I knew that burt would do this.
He's good.
He's crazy.
And take on it.
I knew that you were going to be like
steady.
I'm like,
Tom's not going to slip up.
He's not going to say fuck it.
I need a cheeseburger in the middle of
the night now.
But burt might not eat for a month.
Yes.
Like you might go straight.
What the fuck's his name?
The Batman Guy.
What's his name?
Christian Bale.
When he was in the machinist machinist.
The name of my tour to machinists.
That's the name of my tour.
Everybody.
Berger Chrysler is the machinist.
Do you,
will you send it to me one night like,
you know,
like you go,
you go stop drinking,
stop drinking,
and you go,
Tommy's looks good,
trust me,
and then you're like,
I don't know man.
You got that crazy thing is I call it
the Mickey Mantle gene is that guy that
can go out party all fucking night long,
get up at eight,
get on the field and hit a walk off home
run.
Is that John Daly gene,
that kid,
that gene,
that babe ruth gene,
we eat the hot dog and left field and
then catches the fly ball.
That's what I've always,
I've always admired that in athletes and
stars is those people who can go off
until tiger woods when he's got the
blown out knee and a bad back and he
drains the 90 foot putt.
That's what I don't like.
The fucking Phil Mickelson's over here
is Phil Mickelson drive up the middle
230 yards.
Looks like a little five iron.
I'm fucking going for the green every
time you go and that's the way,
but it's not healthy.
I've had,
I've had no joke,
no joke,
and anyone that's seen me on the road
noses less than a thousand calories
every single day.
Um,
I've dranken only vodka sodas and I've
run at least five miles a day every day,
every day.
Except for yesterday I had,
I had for dinner the night before when
we were weighing in tomorrow.
Guess what he had for dinner?
What?
Pulled pork,
Collard Greens,
and black eyed peas.
It's a tradition that every,
every New Year's Eve we showed her the,
the Black Guy,
the Collard Greens are for money.
I've done it every year and I've made
more money every single year that I've
eaten it.
I'm not going to stop it.
Here's the other thing too,
man.
Technically I know going into this,
I should lose this challenge because I
knew I was bigger and I knew that,
that he could,
if he wanted to be disciplined,
I thought he would,
but I,
I was betting that he wouldn't be
disciplined.
That's the bet.
What you,
you were bigger when it first started.
When I first started,
I knew that like physiologically to
like,
uh,
I just,
I think I have said a little bit more of
a disadvantage,
you know?
What are you saying joe?
Is when he started fat shaming me,
he was fatter than me.
Maybe something about that term.
You said that that term you think is a
good term.
I,
I mean I just said that,
that personally for me,
fat shaming like worked well.
I just feel like that like when somebody
is,
it's more like just being honest.
It's like not in denial when somebody
goes like,
hey man,
you need to lose some weight.
And someone's like,
that's fat shaming.
I go,
well,
yeah,
I think it's just someone being honest.
You know,
that's a bullshit term.
I really do that fat shaming me.
Only it only works if you're fat,
you're fat.
You should lose weight.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
It's,
I have a weird.
I have a weird push and pull with it
because there was a period where I
didn't like it.
I didn't like I,
I empathize with.
I'll just say amy,
because she's the one that gets fat
shaming most.
Hernan,
Kesha are the two most fascinating
people in the country,
one of the best rock stars ever.
She's the best of the best rock star.
So right now,
one of the best rock stars ever.
Dude,
Kesha,
die young is one of the best rock stars
ever.
She's more than a pop star.
I mean,
she'll get at it and we can't see you
over.
And you dehydrate your brain to the
point where it's misfiring.
Kesha eat an ice cube.
I,
I'm waiting for fucking way in,
so I'm going to hydrate soon.
We're going to.
It's going to happen soon.
So,
uh,
so cash and amy are getting fat.
Shamed.
And I would read their comments.
[inaudible] I was going through
something similar.
Not Similar because I think most of mine
were in fun,
but man,
they say they say some mean shit to amy
and Kesha where you're just like,
why say that?
And then I get some of those and I go,
hey,
yeah,
there was a point where like one morning
you wake up,
you're not in the best mood.
And you check your instagram comments
and you're like,
oh fuck,
this is not the way I want to start my
day.
However,
I will say,
had it not been for the fat shaming,
I wouldn't have lost.
I'm going to guess I've probably lost 30
pounds.
You do definitely look better and feel
better,
right?
Dude.
Way To light.
Take off these lower layers.
I look so I feel so much better.
I feel I did.
I jogged eight miles today.
Like I just like.
That wasn't happening when I was 2:50
south thanksgiving.
Go outside or go on my treadmill that
everything's on my treadmill.
I get in,
I'll watch one of those raw workout
videos and get inspired.
The rock dude,
his workout videos are fucking awesome.
Do not follow them on instagram.
He's the best suit when he hit me up.
Do you?
Does anyone remember this day?
In my life
I post.
I work out in the rock shirt.
I always have the rock shirt on.
Which was the bowl?
No,
it's the under armour shirt.
Oh No,
they're not out yet.
They're coming out soon and I'm getting
all of the.
Oh Geez,
you have A.
I have a man crush on the rock,
but also in it's a part of this thing is
finding inspiration to work out that
credence clearwater thing that's real.
That's what I do.
I play that great,
good.
And then you get on the thing and you're
like,
fuck it.
Let's just start running.
Paschal shine a lot on me.
It of just the rock.
Anyway,
I would wear a shirt and I would.
It would,
I would do videos for the rock to see
and in the process I'd workout and
workout because I'd want the roxy and
then he saw one and he was like,
I've made a video where I made a line.
I was like,
uh,
you know,
the fight is.
I go,
I've today,
I'm doing two a days.
For those of you who didn't play
football in high school,
two days for those of you who didn't get
pussy back in high school,
two days and what?
As bad as it did it put hair on her
balls and loved it.
And he goes that today's lion had me
rolling and then he goes,
team Bert.
I lost my shit,
but then I called him.
I go,
you never.
You never did two a days and he was.
I know I played baseball.
It's been the fucking funniest.
Have you guys seen Andrew Sandino's bit
about the rock.
Now that's who it is.
I was trying to tell somebody that I
heard about somebody who has an awesome
fucking hilarious.
It's hilarious.
I want to see it.
I don't want to say any of that to
understand.
Tino came up on my podcast last week,
oddly enough.
He's got red hair.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
I want to see that joey on my podcast
tonight.
Good luck staying sober way and it's
going to be tough tomorrow.
Deaths.
He was on the podcast yesterday.
We did a UFC fight.
Recap with Joey.
He's the best.
He was at my house for fucking Christmas
Eve was destroying my dad.
Did you see the video data,
medical.
He says he did.
We.
It's undisclosed because my dad passed
out hard as fuck and Joanne just walked
out.
Codes are dosed.
Mr K and let me do it before though,
didn't he give him some popcorn before
warm one time at Easter time.
The video is so funny of of Christmas
Day with Joe and and Mr. crusher smoking
and laughing and trying to stop that.
He's like turning to people like he's
just laughing so fucking hard.
I robbed this fucking Puerto Rican and
my dad's a lawyer.
My Dad's going,
Joey,
my dad loves joey.
I literally,
I called Joey like day before Christmas
Eve.
I was like,
you're coming over right?
And he's like,
this is what I love about Joyce.
No fucking bullshit.
He goes,
what time?
Five o'clock.
See you then cock sucker.
And his daughter is like the perfect age
for my daughters to feel like they're
doing something good.
They chase her around.
Horrible.
You guys are like real close to each
other.
Right?
And then when we start to get broken in,
but homeless people play this
real was this
nice little fire pit.
Did one thing killer was fucking around
with Hammond and I'm a kid.
I don't know if he's throwing him up in
the air
that mother fucker.
What you were saying,
you just say homeless people broke in
your house.
Yeah.
A
chunk out of my face
with
the
fucking crazy
Christmas Eve
court.
Yeah.
You told me that story that someone was
walking down your driveway,
some homeless for two to experiences and
because of the construction because
construction and Joe.
Louis,
Joe.
He's the Kinda guy and this is just the
thing.
You didn't say a thing?
Just dog or drop by your house every
night at home.
I drive by just checking to make sure
everything's okay.
Every fucking night.
When he's coming home from the store,
she just drives by my house.
He's a great guy.
He's the greatest man.
He really.
Should we weigh in.
Let's wait.
Let's do this now.
You started out at what?
Wait,
wait,
wait.
Before you.
Before you started,
you started in August,
right?
What were you at your heaviest to?
60 seven.
Holy Shit,
dude.
Yeah.
You were closing in on three.
Holy Shit.
You were to 67.
Wow.
How'd you feel?
I'm not good,
man.
I mean I didn't.
I can't say that like I woke up and they
go,
ah,
feel it.
But I was,
you know,
I was still.
Here's the thing,
at my heaviest,
I would still lift weights a couple of
times a week.
I still would,
I would still do squats,
still do power cleans,
but I was just eating recklessly,
like whatever I wanted.
I was at his house,
I went to dinner at his house,
me and Leanne,
is it their old house?
And uh,
it was right after they had the baby and
Tom cooked us each a steak,
like a full rib eye and then we each got
like nine shrimps and then we each got a
slab of potatoes and then we got a whole
stack of Greens and we didn't need it
all.
And Tom ate at all and he was like,
you didn't like yours?
And we're like,
no,
it's me.
It's a meal for like three people like
that everyday,
you know,
I mean that's how you get to 60 seconds.
So I just felt like,
you know,
and then honestly like clothes too,
it's so something you don't think about,
but you'd be like,
oh I want to get this shirt and you put
it on,
you're like,
you have a bigger shirt.
And they're like,
we don't make bigger than that.
That's the biggest.
And I was like,
man,
you go to gap.
And they're like,
do you guys have forties?
we don't make forties.
And you're like,
oh,
so I've got to shop at a different store
now.
Yeah.
Like this is something I think that has
been in the base of every.
This is.
I also did a showtime special shirtless
during this entire fat shaming campaign,
which did not help what you do every
show shirtless part of the NIH.
Not to like to deflect or whatever.
Part of the reason I started doing a
shortlist as I didn't look good in
collared shirts and like I couldn't wear
a tee shirt and so I just,
I just kinda stayed to rip my shirt off
and I was,
I was a little fat.
I was like 2:50 to 60 now.
People just thought it was funny and I
just leave it off.
I didn't give a fuck.
And then when I like let this weekend I
took my shirt off and I'm not,
I'm not skinny by any stretch of the
means,
but I'm not to 60 anymore to 50 and it
did not get,
just was flat lined and I was like,
okay,
looks like the shorts going back on for
now on the machinist is wearing shirts,
the machinist is going to wear a shirt
machine is the new bird.
So wait,
so to 67 and on our challenge day I
would say I was 2:45.
Right.
So wow.
So you had already dropped like 20
pounds.
Um,
what did,
what did you start at on our challenge
day?
I set out,
I just thought it was two,
five thinking that it wouldn't turn into
a base set to 40.
I said 2:40 the machinist,
but uh,
but on our,
when I got home on the day after,
when I got hold of me you go.
I was actually to 50 to 50 the day when
I started and I was 56 when I started
the Diet,
the I started that I was Thanksgiving to
56 and that that's the probably the
highest I weighed in ever that I saw
myself on a scale to 56.
And so the goal weight was around like
two slash 22 slash 27 slash 27 meant
the,
the deal was this,
whoever is the lowest weight when they
texted me the winner.
But if we're both 2:27 or under,
then the,
the burden of paying for things,
it's supposed to go to Ari.
Oh.
So if you go,
whoo,
I like that.
Yeah.
So does he pay for both trips?
Yes.
Well,
no,
we,
we pick one trip.
We pick one trip but already pays for
the tickets to the trip.
Oh.
So,
but how do you choose what trip?
Because if you win you're going to super
bowl.
Well,
I'll go to the eye to.
Oddly enough I'm in,
I'm in Europe when Tom's talking about
that game.
So I'd go to that game in a heartbeat.
I would explain that if you win,
if I won,
I wanted him to take me to A.
Barcelona is playing a Paris nature main
round of 16 European cub game.
Uh,
so we would go to,
we would go to Paris.
And you told me initially that you
wanted to go to the superbowl.
So I thought it was.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I'd go to Paris jokes.
I'm going to be in London filming or no,
no,
just taking the girls.
Oh,
awesome.
I'll make a lot of money.
So,
uh,
so,
um,
so Ari will pay for that.
He'll,
he'll fly you guys to already be there.
I just need the ticket.
Yeah,
take it.
You should make the flight.
Yeah.
You need to meet us.
I say,
man,
he's off the grid.
Is he going to come meet us?
Yeah.
Why not?
You won't even know how to get in touch
with them.
I don't know.
He probably doesn't have a phone
anymore.
It was based on our BMI.
So when we gave him our original BMI
versus our height,
it was,
we were obese and he said,
I bet you can't get into just simply
overweight and it's simply overweight.
The threshold is 2:27.
So if we got under 2:27,
both of us,
but if one of us today does not get
under to 27,
then that person has to pay for the
trip.
Yeah.
How does that work?
That body mass index because you will,
your body fat or you tied to wait and
it's super outdated and they actually
updated.
There's a newer version called the smart
Bmi which took into account also the
fact that more people are just even
bigger.
Like you're obese.
I guarantee you you're obese.
I'm overweight by the BMI BMI somewhere
in my background.
Some fucked a monkey.
Yeah.
Someone,
someone my great grandpa's Day,
someone fucked a gorilla.
Something happened.
And so that became the bet.
And if we could get into just being
overweight,
which I think personally looking at him
and looking and feeling,
knowing me,
I did not weigh into that because I was
scared.
Um,
but,
uh,
I think like you there,
I think I'm there.
I think I was there before.
I know it was there before yesterday and
then I worked out pretty hard last night
and this morning,
but I didn't want to go on the scale
because I didn't want to come in
down if I wasn't.
Okay.
So first of all,
let's do rock,
paper,
scissors to see who goes first.
Okay.
So Youtube.
Ready?
One,
two,
three.
What are you doing?
What you're doing?
Let me do it.
I'll do the cow.
I'll do the account.
You guys get your hands up.
Ready?
One,
two,
three.
Gotcha.
Okay.
Burt one,
that one,
one,
two,
three.
Okay,
one,
two,
three.
Gotcha.
Okay.
Burt winds.
So would you like to go first or would
you like Tom to go first?
I'd like to weigh in first.
Okay.
I'm so facing thirsty.
So we're going to um,
move over to a toms microphone over
there.
You have a wide shot.
We can get the whole room.
We're going to use a camera up there,
so we'll be using that camera up here.
Here we go.
Are we doing this one carpet?
Do we want to take your clothes off?
First of all,
you definitely want to take your clothes
off.
Well,
I know it works.
Hold on,
but let's make sure we know exactly if
it's exactly right because it may not be
like my scale at home.
I'm always around 200 pounds.
Two.
Oh,
one,
two,
a one with my clothes on.
She was like one night
he's got a rubber suit on the whole.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
So,
uh,
for folks that are just listening here,
we're in the studio here and Jamie is
setting up the camera for Youtube so
that it will point directly down the
scale.
Bert is a looking considerably slimmer,
considerably slimmer.
He's got multiple layers on and now he's
down to underwear,
which are probably wet.
He took the first layer of underwear or
socks,
a drum roll.
Ladies and gentlemen.
BOMP bomp.
Bomp.
He's drying himself off like a wrestling
tournament.
Jesus Christ.
Okay,
here we go.
Below 27 everybody.
Here we go.
Bert Kreischer called out.
Joe
Two 21.
Holy Shit.
Oh No.
But it's right,
I checked my own weight.
It's right.
This is what I use at home too.
But we can,
we can try with
35.
Yeah.
Thirty four points.
That's it.
Twenty one,
22,
21.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Holy Shit.
I mean Shit Joe.
My prediction was Tommy wasn't going to
take his shirt off.
He's got to.
Now that shirt is precious ounces to 21.
My man went hard.
Fuck.
Yes.
Cyborg.
Oh,
I have my watch on that.
So probably at least a few ounces.
That's a good watch.
It's a beautiful watch by them and make
a,
a drink while it's going on.
Oh my goodness.
This is.
This is chaos.
Here we go.
Tommy.
Looking very slim to.
Here we go.
Ladies and gentlemen,
show fuck.
Holy Shit.
Wow.
First of all,
congratulations to the both of you for
that is gigantic.
So Thursday.
It's ridiculous.
We've got some coconut water.
If you want to get some electrolytes in
you.
Holy Shit.
You guys want to coconut water?
No,
I'm good.
God,
you might go get water or their calories
in this.
Uh,
no.
None at all.
It's a Stevia.
It's called via sodium Tommy.
Holy Shit.
Wow.
So those extra pounds or whatever,
you know,
you didn't drink water that made up for
it.
God Damn,
we got gotta.
Do this all again together tomorrow of.
Wait,
what happens tomorrow?
Let's take some moral one.
Victory.
Well here man,
let's sit down.
Let's sit down.
Okay?
We go.
We got this out of the way.
Oh my God.
I'm so thirsty.
Wow.
Very impressive.
Tommy,
you went from two,
you say to 67,
two,
six,
seven down to 2:19.
Holy Shit.
That's amazing.
You could see it in your face to Jesus.
You know that video that uh,
I took a still of it and I put it up on
instagram today.
Yeah,
but that one video I was looking at your
face.
I'm like,
Jesus,
you look so fucking healthy.
Thanks.
He's busted.
Open his food when he got there from
chicken,
little pieces,
a dry chicken,
fucking broccoli and stuff.
I just can't eat today.
I just can have fluid today and then
fucking go to Berkeley.
Sweat it out.
Are you thinking about that?
Pulled pork and black ips and all that
jazz.
You ate and you think that might have
fucked you?
I think I'm,
I don't know.
I think I'm fucking shocked.
Um,
to 21 to be amazing.
Amazing.
It's amazing.
You both look great.
You really do your faces like you look
like two different people.
I know.
It is weird.
When I saw him we were at all things
comedy of the day and I walked up behind
him and I didn't recognize him.
I go,
you went from the little cuddly chubby
friend I have where we giggle to this
dude who looks like you video tells you
the tapes himself fucking.
But you guys are like,
you're,
you.
You're like,
we'll close to getting down to 200
hundred
pounds.
Do consider this in like 30 days.
Yeah.
You could do you,
you both could be 200 pounds.
Yeah,
I will.
The thing is,
you know,
I don't want to,
like,
I haven't changed my lifestyle at all
technically.
Like I've changed the way I eat.
I eat so fucking clean right now.
Like literally,
except for last night,
I've only had lean proteins and greens
for every meal I do.
Big Truck in.
You're the
whole comp checks?
Yeah,
hulk loads.
Hope I call outcome.
I do.
I do those shakes like once a day and
I'm,
I'm under a thousand calories.
My wife,
what's upsetting her?
And she's like,
how do we transition this into a healthy
lifestyle,
which is,
which is fine,
I think once you get c's right.
Yeah.
And it's like I can't continue this.
No.
Like I had to push back a cardiologist
appointment.
I was like,
I don't want them to see me like this.
Like I'll,
I'll wait until I get healthy again.
You know,
this is not entirely healthy to just
drain yourself and dehydrate yourself
like chicken so much.
You're like a dog that just got back
from the park.
You know what's crazy is it.
I understand I watched Chris Cyborg
breaking like weight loss thing.
Did you see that?
Yeah,
it's horrible.
And I watched it and I thought if I can
have half that intensity,
that whole time I watched at the
beginning the weight loss.
I said if I gonna have half her
intensity in that moment.
What did,
uh,
what did she do?
Oh Dude,
she's crying.
It's all made.
Wait.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And share bodies apparently really
fucked up from it.
She just got,
she is pissed hot for um,
some sort of a.
well,
it's really difficult to say exactly
what's going on because what she took
was something called spironolactone,
which is illegal in Usada.
You're not allowed to take it,
but her doctor,
she says,
told her she could take it out of
competition.
She passed on a bunch of title fights
though the UFC was concerned.
So they tested her and apparently people
take that it's a diuretic and a,
what she was saying was that share of
bodies all fucked up and hanging onto
water now.
And then she's taking this just to try
to leverage those herself out because
draining herself down to 1:40 was so bad
for her that her whole system all fucked
up.
The controversy is though that that same
drugs also taken by people who are women
who do steroids to mimic,
to minimize the effects of testosterone.
Okay.
So we don't really know.
I mean it's their word.
Who knows,
who knows?
But it's amazing when you watch what you
watch when you're.
When you're focusing on getting in
shape,
moving.
I watched this guy rich froning.
Do you know who that goes to?
Crossfit champ,
dude.
He is like,
he's a savage.
She has a borderline sociopath.
Like the way he focuses on workout,
working out.
It's just like he's almost dead inside.
There's no enjoyment to it.
It's almost like an obsession.
So I started looking at it like that,
like don't like don't enjoy jogging,
just make an obsession.
Like my thing was I get on the treadmill
and go just one more mile.
Just do one more mile.
You do that.
Everyone would do one more mile like
tea.
Like this morning I was like,
I was like,
maybe one maybe if you're on this mile
at a seven,
maybe that'll make the difference today.
And I just would get obsessive about
that brain.
What's five?
So little things in my body.
If I touch that fucking explode.
Just kidding tonight.
Oh yeah.
When my daughters for a little exercise,
I'm looking at it that way.
I'm going to look at.
It is fun.
I look,
I was burning calories now.
Uh,
how are we going to do this in terms of
tomorrow?
Because you guys are real close.
Yeah.
So you are to 19 to 21.
We're only talking about a couple of
pounds.
So those couple of pounds.
What if one of you loses more than that?
Tomorrow.
But like what if Bert gets down to like
two.
Oh,
six tomorrow or something ridiculous.
I don't know.
What do we do?
That's a good question.
Average out the to wait.
Well we average out the two weights.
It's whoever loses the most overall
or is it because otherwise we're just
going to have a draw or a victory?
Right.
Like if you,
if you want again tomorrow,
it's easy,
right?
Because you want it today.
But if burt wins tomorrow,
but what if he wins tomorrow by the
exact same amount?
Talking about total weight loss or just
whoever's lighter.
We're just saying that like what if
tomorrow we come in and you weigh two
pounds less than me?
Tomato,
right,
but then like we each one one day.
So you were to 21 year or two?
19.
Correct.
Okay.
So we're really only dealing with two
pounds.
That's,
that's so negligible.
I mean that's,
that's,
that's uh,
a few of these.
Yeah,
I mean you can,
you can suck that out of your body.
That can be done.
So the question is how do you,
uh,
like what if tomorrow Bert winds,
but he only winds by half pound,
right?
When does 10?
So I have to win by three pounds.
Well that's what I'm trying to.
We're trying to figure out like how can
you might as well shave my beard right
now can get the regrow it started
already.
This is,
it gets kind of dangerous because you
guys are gonna.
You guys are gonna hit that,
that Freakish di you guys take anything
taking any diuretics or anything like.
Oh I haven't restarted that.
Recommended it.
So I would say I was your friend
diuretics,
I would say.
Do they happen at the cvs?
Oh yeah.
What happens?
Shit.
Your brains out pits like the fucking
race horse shit.
And like three days calories.
Um Man,
this is a,
this is where it gets squirrely because
you guys are on the wire.
I mean clearly tom one,
but he only won by two pounds.
Yeah,
that's the wire.
You
guys can't believe that because I
thought you'd win by thought I thought
I'd wait to 27.
He came in and he's like,
I think I'm to 27.
I was like,
oh Jesus.
Okay.
That's marathons running marathons.
Wow.
Yeah.
You,
you've been literally doing marathons?
Yeah,
I don't do them all at once.
I break it up during the day so I get up
at like six,
have a cup of coffee,
walking like a three point five,
walk a mile in like 17 minutes and then
sit down with a computer,
see if I'm trending and see what is he
up,
my facebook.
I will abuse all my facebook video and
then get back on and then I'll run
around like two miles.
Then go fuck around with the girls,
come back,
get on.
That's the way I do it.
I break it up.
So like right now I got eight miles on
the treadmill.
I'll do a podcast with joey tonight,
get back on the treadmill,
Bang on another eight,
and I was 16 miles today.
Wow.
I know you walked in running a mix.
What I'd like to do,
my favorite thing to do is I walk a
hundred yards on the treadmill and then
I run 300 yards,
so like a a run at seven point five over
200 over half
of the lap around the circle so that the
other day.
When you post that video and is five
hours,
was that broken up or to the day?
Starting at 6:00 AM.
Ending it like probably probably nine at
night.
Like yesterday I went,
I ran three miles first thing in the
morning,
then went to the rams game,
put on pulled pork on the green,
big green egg,
went to the rams game a cooked it 300
degrees perfectly for five hours.
Thank you.
Eric Rosen.
When you put it on the big green egg,
how do you keep the temperature stable
for that long?
You regulate it with the pipe,
the pipe up top and the bottom,
and you just put Philip charcoals and
once you get it to like 2:25,
if you've got it regulated,
it's not going to go much higher because
it's not getting much air in and then
slowly the charcoals a burn and then it
just cooks.
You don't open it,
it just cooks and if you open it all the
way it's going to get way high gets when
you were like 700 degrees.
Yeah,
I've got one of those.
I have a commodity,
but it's basically the same thing.
Have you ever tried it with one of those
pellet grills though?
Oh God,
I wish I remembered his name.
What's his name?
Brett.
Yes.
I love my green mountain grill.
I just a new pellet.
So that thing is fucking better than
anything.
You put it in there and you're like
2:25,
five hours.
Perfect.
Yeah,
it stays at that temperature.
What kind of grill is it?
It's a pellet grill.
What they do is they take,
you know when you go to flex my home,
my voice.
Did you know if you go to a lumber yard
and they cut up,
saw a hardwood sawdust from the
hardwood,
they take that stuff and they compress
it and the natural sugars in the wood
allows them to compress it down to what
looks like it looks like a serial or
kitty litter or something like little
tiny like cylinders,
little small cylinders,
and they take that and you pour it into
this hopper,
so it's this like large bin and then
there's a worm drive at the bottom that
slowly turns this stuff into a heating
element and the heating element is
inside the chamber of this big steel box
and the heating element.
There it is.
You see it there.
Those are the pellets.
So those are hard wood pallets.
There's no gluing them,
has no nothing.
It's just the natural sugars from the
wood and when you use the machine,
when you close that lid there,
you get to see it there.
You can regulate the temperature and it
keeps it exactly at that temperature is
low in that,
that popper that'll last for fucking 10,
12 hours.
Yeah.
Especially.
It's amazing.
They're incredible.
And how hot can it.
Can it go full?
$600?
I have one that is a.
it's a Yoda.
It's like a really good one.
It's like made out of cast iron is real.
Fucking heavy.
Yoder makes these amazing smokers and
mine has a direct heating option.
We you take out that big diffusion plate
and you put in these grill grates and it
has direct fire that goes right
underneath the grill grates.
I see your stakes on it and I cook elk
on it all the time to the best.
It amazing.
It really is.
And you get that smoky flavor to it too
because it's cooking with fire.
It's wood and fire.
So it's got a beautiful flavor to the
food if you don't want us.
What I do sometimes my daughters don't
like smoked food is all wrapped some
ribs
up in tin foil and put them in there and
they still cook like an oven.
An oven.
It's still cooks at 2:25.
And then you smoke to other racks.
Dude,
it's fucking amazing.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's like you're cooking with an oven,
but it's all fire instead of gas,
heat or whatever the hell.
Electric heat.
I love it man.
So why did you,
why'd you use the green mountain grill
instead of the or why'd you use the big
green egg instead of the Green Mountain
girl?
I wanted to see if I could use it.
I just got it.
My Dad got it for me for Christmas and
uh,
because I like the ritual of cooking.
Like I like the ritual of like starting
up charcoal and you know,
and then getting it into it.
And then so,
so yesterday I ran three miles through a
pull on these to a Boston butts bone in
Boston butts and then closed it and then
it's made things fun.
I'm sit at the fucking rams game going,
going like,
I wonder if the girls too hot,
like,
shit,
fuck it.
It's like it makes it,
it's like betting on a game.
By the way,
went to the rams came yesterday.
I told Tommy with a Jersey that had the
machine written on the back of it.
Oh God never been recognized more and my
fucking life mean dudes were coming down
to my seat going,
hey,
can I get a picture
back of my shirt is fucking,
it was a gift from my management company
and it's a Rams Jersey.
And I was like,
I'll fucking wear it.
As soon as I walked in the stadium,
big dude goes,
Shane.
And then I turned around and he goes,
Oh shit,
it's the machine.
And I was like,
you just thought it was some dude,
a dude with the machine on the back.
He was like,
Domo,
Shane and I turned around.
He's like,
my daughter's like,
dad,
fucking stop it.
Yeah.
That must be embarrassing for the kids.
Have you ever thought about getting one
of them?
Uh,
offset smokers?
We throw logs in.
They're like those old school Texas
style ones.
Yeah.
Yeah,
me too.
Put it the back corner by the chickens
and just have like a big,
uh,
like oil.
Can you just open up?
I love one of those.
Yeah.
Those seem like that's the real ritual,
right?
Yeah.
I had a barrel grill.
You know where you,
you have to take off the greats after
like while you're cooking to keep adding
coal and wood chips to it,
you know?
Oh,
old school.
Old School.
Yeah.
There's something about women.
I appreciate that.
Is that a male thing?
I think I like working with fire.
So yeah,
I don't see a whole lot of women.
I know not a lot.
I'm sure that there definitely are,
but it's not like they can't do it,
but I don't see a lot.
What the hell is that?
Like what women like to cook,
but men want to cook outside over fire.
I think it's.
I think it's primal.
Yeah.
I cooked up.
You gave me the elk last time.
Got More if you want.
Yeah,
I do because I haven't heard tomorrow
though.
I cook it up and I won't getting pieces
of liberty here tomorrow.
Fuck yeah.
We're getting fucked up tomorrow after
weigh ins.
If I don't have a beard,
I will be drinking vodka and I'll be
making him drink vodka.
So we bring a razor.
We should.
Yeah,
but we're the dollar shave club when you
need them.
Either one of my sponsors,
so I'm very raised.
You didn't need an electric one.
Are you looking at me last today?
I'll bring upbringings.
I got clever.
You can shave me,
but we're using my clippers.
Okay.
Well why don't I already giving up.
I'm,
I'm by the way.
I'll shave you.
Well,
but what?
You'd have to.
We have to figure out how you can win.
I thought was just personally.
That is lowest.
Well he won.
Today is two day way in.
So he went into that.
So if you get lower tomorrow,
he would have to get lower than two
pounds.
Lower.
Holy Shit.
Because it has to be.
It has to be a victory overall,
right?
I mean,
what,
don't you agree?
Yeah.
No,
we should let people weigh in on the,
on twitter.
Don't do that.
No,
don't do that.
You can.
You tell them too many people on
protocol already.
Let's call her basement with a dick in
their hand.
Typing with one hand and not paying
attention.
Call are just texted me a good luck on
the way in.
So I hope you're not fat or too late.
Yeah,
I was going to say that at this point.
He,
um,
uh,
he's already paying for stuff.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I'm not gaining.
Yeah,
eight pounds tomorrow.
Yeah.
Right now he's trying to figure out how
to unclip his phone.
Yeah.
Oh.
He's still committed to that flip phone.
I can't believe it's a flip.
Lowman mumbling.
He sent me.
He's got a mouthful of fucking shoe
laces.
Ari.
Hey
Ari,
he's talking to someone else in the
answers the phone don't hang up.
No,
no,
no.
He'll get to you eventually.
I can't believe this human.
We're friends.
Hold on.
Ridiculous.
Silly.
He's the best though.
I just love what he's done.
Like very few people get wealthy and
like I've known since he was a,
he was a doorman at the fucking store
and he was an open mic or when we became
friends and when he became famous,
one of the first things that fucking guy
did was abandoned all fucks.
Yeah.
He doesn't have any.
None.
Zero.
I mean zero.
Pretty awesome.
Can you hear me
now?
He's in the middle of a podcast.
He's in the middle of.
It.
Sounds like gangs podcast.
He already.
Can you hear me?
Sorry.
Do hear me
or you didn't get your money back.
You get the
feeling that he's answering your phone
might be a message.
Yeah.
Let's call him again and see if it's his
outgoing message,
which is hilarious.
Texted me.
What'd you say?
Fuck yourself.
Good luck today.
I've been hoping you win since day one.
That's the same message you sent to Tom.
Let's see if it's the same exact message
because if it is then how funny would
that be?
As outgoing message is terrible.
Was in the middle of a conversation just
to confuse people.
Could we use to do that?
Remember?
Yeah.
I still fall for those again.
Give me one second.
Let me get the deep.
Can we please leave your message for
fear that's not as outgoing message.
Fuck them.
Let's keep calling them.
Fluids number tasted better in my entire
fucking life.
I don't know how these professional
fighters do it.
They get paid though.
Yeah,
and they're savages.
Yeah.
It's not easy,
man.
Hello?
Hey,
you're alive.
Bert Kreischer to 21.
Thompson Agora to 19.
Wow.
Yeah,
we're on the air right now.
Twenty one to 21,
like a fucking gangster and then tom
gets on it to 19
below obese.
They're both below a b,
so you have to pay for the trip.
You fuck how you feel about that?
Yeah,
no way.
you got to measure the measure that.
No,
no,
no.
It's my scale.
It's a scale and we put weights on it.
Their heights were both six one,
six one.
You said you'd pick one.
He's only five percent were the same
height?
No,
he's not.
He's six.
One was coming out.
It's like you were in the elevators to
the Jew in you is trying to save some
money
for
nothing.
Six one.
Stand up.
Stand up please.
Tommy Tommy,
stand out.
Okay.
They're going to stand up for them.
For the both of them to Berta.
They both had no pants out by the way,
but it looks a little taller.
Maybe not much.
Maybe a half an inch to.
Well,
I don't know.
Yeah,
I would say,
but it's hard because your hair's a
little flattened up and tom's a little
thinner on top.
Flatten that out.
Flatten your hair down.
One more time,
please.
Stand up.
Go back to back.
Let's take a look at this here.
Yeah,
listen,
it's the difference in height is maybe a
half an inch,
maybe a half.
An inch bar might be a inch tall.
And Burt,
how
tall are you?
I'm 61.
He's six months old.
Tom's probably six and a half.
Yeah,
they're both under obese,
bro.
You lose
BMI calculator and figure that out.
Okay.
We'll go into a BMI calculator.
So we.
Here's the question to you since since
Thomson one today by two pounds,
we're saying tomorrow,
Bert has to win by more than two pounds.
If burt wants to win overall,
does that sound correct to you?
Suddenly waiting.
The final cut?
No.
No,
because Tom one by two pounds today.
So Tom has won victory under his belt.
If burt wins by two pounds tomorrow,
it's just a.
it's a draw.
So he would have to win by more than two
pounds because that's the amount of
victory that Tom got today.
I think they brought sweat a bunch and
this is why we did multiple days because
tomorrow's Day would be for a little
more,
but we couldn't do a draw,
but I would say yeah.
Okay.
So we.
We added their weight up six foot one
and 2:21 for burt in the body mass.
The overall body mass index is 29 point
two two.
He's overweight only.
She's overweight only that's not obese.
Okay.
What about six?
Six.
Okay.
Let's see.
Let's just go with going to be
overweight.
I've already done this.
It's overweight and we just went with
straight six feet without even the half
inch and a quarter,
but put me in at five.
10,
put me or a five.
Eight rather
a
Tommy did know.
Obese.
Look at this.
I'm obese.
Five eight.
It's ridiculous,
but that's hilarious.
If five,
eight,
200.
I'm obese and they're not.
Who's got the lower BMI?
I got a six pack.
Yeah.
So what do you think?
Do you think that that's how it should
be?
That Tom,
that bird has to win by more than two
pounds tomorrow?
Does that seem fair?
Ohio?
And maybe let's see who's got the lower
BMI
should be the final way because they
couldn't have
any water today.
They couldn't do that two days in a row.
No,
they can't because they're going to
rehydrate.
They definitely could do it two days in
a row.
Who's got the lower BMI by one?
I think.
I think he's.
I think there was a blind way in today
and it wouldn't be fair if you base it
on what burt already knows because Bert
already has a goal.
Now.
See today was all about willpower and
Tom one that it was all about willpower.
Who's losing the most weight?
Who Comes in the light?
Alright.
He has spoken,
but you're going to have to pay for the
trip.
You understand that right?
You have to bring a tape measure.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
Tape measures.
He's actually.
No,
no,
no.
Wait a minute.
He already got your dad shrunk.
Old people shrink here already conceded
that old.
They're not old to the point where
they're shrinking.
He's like,
my dad,
he was six feet.
It was really like five,
10 because he used to be six feet was.
Yeah.
People shrink
away
by the way.
He can.
You can.
You can stop right there.
The goal weight was the goal weight was
to 27 or so.
You will last well into just overweight.
Yeah.
That was the goal.
We
get the tape measure measure.
Okay.
Listen,
to make you happy because you're the one
who was going to have to pay.
We will.
We will measure height and then we'll
measure weight.
Okay.
All right.
We gotta go.
Love you.
Faggot.
Wow.
Cheap piece of shit.
Piece of shit.
He makes a bet and then horrible.
First of all,
he's got his money and nothing.
We have children.
He doesn't spend money on shit.
I told art and always making fucking
bank.
He's selling out everywhere.
He's got his shows on its third season.
He's killing it everywhere and I go get
a nice car.
Get yourself like a little bmw and
infinity or something.
Listen to his podcast with me and run is
easy.
Why can understand the concept of a
fucking mortgage lending that before the
podcast even started that he was getting
angry that you have a mortgage,
like why would you do that?
Because the whole premise was we
borrowed money against our house to do a
renovation,
which is make make sense.
You know,
you,
your health is worse.
House,
his house is worth more than you start.
You paid for it,
so you borrow against that.
Take out $200,000 and you renovate it
and then you make your house worth more,
but your mortgage is still very small
considering that you've only borrowed a
minimal amount of money.
Right?
Or he couldn't wrap his head around
that.
No,
that's not your money.
Money.
He yells,
he gets mad and yell.
Here's the other guy do.
He's
going to end up trying to.
Like if he does have to pay for this,
pay for it,
for like in the cheapest way possible.
It will be like last stand is like,
he's known me forever and I've never
worried about money like I've always
just said,
just spend it and live.
You don't.
You're not here forever.
You just have a good time.
Don't go crazy.
Don't buy a bunch of Shit you can't
afford,
but definitely don't think about it.
The best thing about money,
the number one thing about money,
that's the best thing about it is when
you make money,
you don't have to think about it.
Meaning that your bills are paid.
I remember when I got my first
development deal when I was 25,
20,
somewhere around then and all of a
sudden I felt light.
I felt like I got a check and it was
like 100 grand or something like that,
and I was like,
oh,
I don't have to feel.
I'm not thinking about money.
It was the craziest feeling.
It was like I felt lighter.
I felt like like a weight literally had
been lifted off my shoulders.
Like it actually physically felt like
the stress of how am I owe the fucking.
Oh.
Then there's the phone bill,
the gas bill.
Oh,
there's the rent.
there's the car.
All that shit was gone.
Yeah.
It's an amazing.
That's a number one good thing about
money.
It's not about like castles and
Ferrari's and all that bullshit and it's
about not worrying about it.
That's the number one thing is you make
great money.
You don't have to worry about a fucking
mortgage.
You'd find stupid.
He's crazy.
He's out.
He doesn't.
He just couldn't wrap his head around it
and we tried to make it very simple.
Pretend you have a backpack.
Now I want to say I'd like to borrow
against that backpack and put stuff in
your backpack.
Your backpack is more valuable.
He's like,
I don't understand backpacks.
Like he,
he doesn't even have a watch.
Yeah,
just to look at his phone or ask
somebody if he wants to know what time
it is.
And his phone was made in the twenties.
Stupid fucking flip phone.
He barely knows what time it is.
It's.
Yeah.
It's like he's eating shoes while he's
talking to you.
Like he's got a mouthful of like an
undigestible thing.
Makes a living talking more or he's a
professional orator.
Yeah.
Ridiculous.
He tried to get out of this.
I want to breather.
When you merged with their heart,
their lawyer,
their lawyer.
I've mentioned about God,
he said he was six one.
How about the fact that we both lost a
considerable amount of weight?
He doesn't care.
He's thinking about his money going
away.
Watch what?
He's so crazy.
Wait a fucking stereotyping apart right
now.
He's.
He's,
he's making a suit and some shoes.
Does it Taylor?
It's such a silly boy.
Such a silly.
Should make them wear horns to this
game.
I just feel like.
I mean,
how much would it cost to fly you to
Paris and.
Well,
that's actually pretty expensive,
right?
Yeah.
We're not going coach.
How are you going to that?
It's like 25 grand.
We're overweight and we can't fly.
Coach.
Yeah,
you're overweight.
Twenty five.
I'm obese.
That's what.
That's why they,
they the skills wrong.
If you look up,
look up,
scale up.
Hilarious.
Smart Bmi.
Hm.
Have you seen that?
That's the one that they developed a
little bit later.
That's supposed to be a little more
like,
you know,
progressive in terms of knowing that
hitting 200 and more is more along the
norm for a lot of grown.
Like,
I don't know if you would read,
you won't register the same way you did
on that BMI.
It was just.
It was.
It was developed later,
so they must be the real way to do it as
a check.
Actual body fat.
Yeah.
To get a real test.
That's a real body medicine.
This thing at my crossfit place where
they were,
you can see they bring in like a tank of
water and you sit in a tank water.
That's how you really are supposed to
do.
That's the Shit and then it tells you
like
how many calories you burn in a day or
how many shoe need to burn.
They do that with a combine,
like they get people's body map.
I'd love that.
Yeah.
If anyone's listening,
Tom and I will totally go to a combine
and do a combine.
That's the other thing we want to sell.
We wanted to do a show burgers for
already verse Tom were the three of us
make bets against each other and just
outrageous beds because let's be fucking
honest,
in one month we've lost a considerable
amount of weight.
If you had a time lapse of that,
if you had a just a a show shooting that
it will be fun just to call out videos
we've been doing to each other.
They've been fucking hilarious.
Probably a 35 pounds.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
In a month.
That's crazy.
And you've lost probably.
What did you think you were a month ago?
Because you've been more steady.
I been more steady.
Yeah.
I mean up one day and he goes,
this isn't fun,
man.
He's like,
this is because this isn't a good idea.
Like this is unhealthy.
And I was like,
yeah,
I know.
I go,
you started at asshole.
I want to be fucking eating 500 calories
getting on a treadmill every day.
I'm using a fucking toenail.
If you,
if you started with the start,
wait,
it's 48 pounds for me,
but then Jesus in the last,
uh,
probably in the last month,
it's probably like 25
to pick up that 35 pound kettle bell and
realize that you lost 10 pounds more
than that.
Just pick that up.
The smaller one.
Just feel that.
Feel that.
Yeah.
And feel that that's 35 pounds.
You've lost that in a fucking month,
dude.
That's crazy.
I don't want to feel it.
Yeah.
Feel that they think about like walking
around with that all day.
What a burden that is.
Plantar Fasciitis.
Yeah.
Oh for sure man.
Your feet are carrying the whole weight.
Yeah.
So it's really,
it's amazing what you guys have done
just because it's fun.
I mean it's kind of fun,
but it's obviously a lot of work,
but I mean because you guys had this
like fun challenge and it became this
big thing.
It's definitely.
I mean like I feel like you definitely
want to live more around this weight.
Right?
Going forward.
Oh yeah.
This will be great.
This would be great.
You'd like to get lower.
Ideally I'd like to be 2:15.
We'll be cool.
But yeah,
you're not that funny.
Fat and you're like if you take your
shirt off,
it's not funny and I would like to stop
taking my shirt off.
Yeah.
Well,
I've told you this in a store,
like I don't take my shirt off at the
store,
have taken it off,
but normally I don't like if I do a
setting the alarm,
I'll take my shirt off.
Right.
I don't think about taking my shirt off.
It's just,
you know,
it's one of those things not automatic
with you that it happened organically
and then it was one of the things that
I,
when I did my special,
I talked to my buddy cowhead,
my counselor,
and he was just like,
you're not going to do with your shirt
on run.
I was like,
I haven't really thought about it.
And he's like,
he's like,
the thing I like about watching you to
stand up is it doesn't seem like it's
different.
He's like,
your first special,
you were dressed up and I get really
fucked up in my head about what to wear
on stage.
That really kind of gets in my head
about like,
I don't want to put on a costume.
Yeah.
Right.
So for me,
taking my shirt off was just being.
It was authentic.
It was what you were doing because you
were doing that for the last couple of
years.
I've been doing it for like five,
seven years.
Is that.
How long have you been doing that?
Yeah,
the shirt off.
It started.
Yeah,
seven years.
I've been formed with a shirt on on the
road and I don't you,
you can't find a picture of me a lot of
times.
First show,
after the show I'll put my shirt on to
take pictures with people,
but I have so many pictures of me and my
shirt off just because it was a,
it felt real.
It felt.
Remember,
let me ask you this because uh,
when I'm sick,
if I go on stage,
I don't feel right.
I feel off like I feel weak when you
guys are doing this,
you're,
you're draining your body.
So it's almost like you're sick.
It's like,
what are your sets been like?
I'll,
I,
I'll tell you,
the Tampa was the day I started to
really started when I went to Tampa.
By the way,
I've been on the road this whole fucking
month doing this weight loss.
I've done every fucking week on the road
and in Tampa.
I was not good.
I was dizzy,
I couldn't get my hands warm
Florida,
you can't get your hands warm.
That was crazy.
I was dizzy and I was like,
I don't even think I was drinking a
little bit,
but I wasn't drinking much and I,
but I wasn't eating.
That was the other thing.
I wasn't eating any calories and I th,
I think,
and I'm sure if we got a doctor to tell
me this,
I think I was probably prediabetic and
then when I stopped taking in all sugar
all together,
my body just went fucking crazy.
There was a set where I was like,
I was dizzy and I,
they were sending up juice to the stage
so I could get sugar in my body low like
you ask them to do that.
But yeah,
they sent up a cranberry juice and then
I drove in one day and I was like
shivering and I pulled into mcdonalds,
got an orange juice,
and I was like,
something's fucking wrong.
My parents were worried,
but then right after that I started
feeling good and then I got to like Fort
Lauderdale and I was like,
Bam,
I'm on a roll.
I was in Omaha.
Omaha is the best.
I started losing weight.
I started feeling good,
and then they were doing a topless shots
upstairs.
$3 shot topless shots once a tablet
shot,
everyone was fucking naked to the people
that we're serving shots.
Are you everyone in the audience?
The whole audience?
What the fuck?
Yeah.
So it was just everyone upstairs,
topless.
And if you were top of got a $3 shot,
tits death threat,
it was fucking amazing.
It was the smartest thing was an Indie
mortise comedy joined is the smartest
thing they ever did.
Everyone walked away with that,
like,
you know what I mean?
Like I don't know that they care.
Yeah.
It seems like they don't care in this
picture.
Yeah.
I send it to Tom.
Oh yeah.
The best picture I sent to Tom here.
Wait,
let me show it.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
As long as you're in Indianapolis,
he could pull that shit off.
Yeah.
You can't get away with that.
Do that in New York to put you in jail
for sure.
You have to have a license to date.
Day Two of cutting sugar.
We did a live podcast and that was in a
bad fucking mood,
man.
Yeah.
Shut up.
And I said something to the manager and
then I heard Christina.
She was like,
just stay out of his way because I was
like snap.
I didn't meet.
I apologized later,
but it was,
I was real irritated.
So I texted this picture to Tom and I
was like,
weight loss is doing good.
Tell me what you think.
Hog
Photoshop.
Yeah.
Fucking ridiculous.
It was like,
it was kind of on the line,
right?
So I was like,
Jesus man.
He was like.
And then he wrote like,
oops,
I didn't mean to send it to your waist
down.
Modified tweeters,
those.
And then he called daughters.
Actually
Marino.
You did go,
I was showed it to Paul Young Rom on
their last day and Dan Marino sat down
and I still had it on my phone.
I go,
Dan,
you've been in a lot of locker rooms.
What do you think about this?
And he goes,
hey,
you were with Captain Leanne from below
deck on that.
Who's that?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Some reality show.
But what,
what reality shows below deck below deck
is like a,
it's chart yard,
which I can't say yacht charters and
they have.
So you have like it follows the crew and
then the guests.
Right?
So below deck is the crew and the guests
are upstairs.
So it's just like a nonsense reality
show,
but they are running out of fucking top.
It's super entertaining.
I get lost and yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean like as a fluff show,
like it's something to watch as you like
it.
A lot of stupid shows though,
right?
A lot of stupid shit.
You ever fucking ever see his promotions
for his tour?
It's just some black lady putting on
cream.
Do you ever have some of the people that
are.
Actually,
the people from that video contact you
after you put their videos up.
Promos.
Not as.
I don't think I'm the promos yet.
I've had it from um,
from your mom's house.
Like videos,
like throat Zilla.
Yeah.
She reached out.
Um,
she follows me.
She came to a show.
She follows me.
Yeah,
that one I had to be really weird.
Right.
I wasn't expect she was like posting,
you know,
I'm going to come to this show or that
show.
And I was just like,
you know,
I didn't respond.
I didn't know like if it was serious or
not anyways.
And then she just showed up and goes
like,
I don't want my picture taken.
And then she was wearing a shirt that
said throat,
throat,
Zilla Google me.
So I was like,
oh,
okay.
But she was super nice.
Very nice.
So you got over like what you really
think that you were prediabetic.
Might've been you.
Did you,
um,
you want to throw in the towel for
tomorrow?
We want to go for it.
I'm going for it.
Okay.
Is already paying no matter what the
burdens off you guys.
It's just a beard thing now.
It's not beard thing.
He's very upset.
Very upset.
I heard that.
He's trying to roll it back.
Doesn't believe your heights?
Yeah.
Lauren.
Find out how tall they would have to be
to be obese.
Go to have done this so much.
I can tell you which.
If I was six foot,
I'm still overweight.
Yeah.
It was like 5:11.
That would have been six foot.
It was real close.
Will suffer.
Sure.
He's lost.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's definitely a bought Tom and I've
already talked to this ad nauseum and I
trust me,
I've looked at that BMI scale a lot
going on.
You're going to measure.
We just had a physical three or four
months ago where they measured your
height and everything.
Yeah.
He doesn't believe the scales.
Right?
I am going to my cardiologist next week.
Next week I rescheduled it.
I was like,
I'm in the middle of this weight loss
challenge and it's not super healthy and
I kind of don't want to see you now.
I was like,
can I see it?
Yeah.
I think you losing all this weight the
way you're doing it,
I don't think it's really going to fuck
with your heart that much.
I don't think it's a bad thing is.
I don't know
right now dehydrated.
They will probably have some sort of
effect.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
I was supposed to go in last week and I
was just like,
I don't wanna I don't want to go in.
And him being like,
hey listen,
you know you're [inaudible] I gotta got
something going on with my thyroid that
they've never really figured out,
so I don't want it to be like,
you're fucking with your thyroid.
I was like,
let's just get through this.
This is fun by the way.
That's the other part of this is that
none of this was like,
it's all healthy.
I want to be healthy.
I want to be.
I want to live long.
I want to see my kids get married.
Fucking already posted a tweet about
that would've burned gains weight.
Then you'll be in heaven and some other
man will be holding his daughter's hand
walking her down the aisle fucking
already.
Sometimes ruthless,
ruthless,
ruthless.
It's almost like he's like a.
he's got asperger's or something like
the way he just like when he went,
when I walked in his room that day,
the day the challenge started,
he's just like,
I was like,
what's up?
And he's like,
you're fat,
you're obese.
Oh my God,
It's disgusting.
You're,
you're obese.
And then I'm like,
okay,
it's good seeing you already.
How you doing?
He said,
I was going to talk to you about family,
but you're just obese and you're like,
I'm here for like an hour.
I gotta run back to OPI radio.
Do you want to.
Can we do a podcast?
Wow.
You're just so fat.
How fast do you think Tom is?
Oh yeah.
That's how it started is already just
fucking see.
He probably wouldn't be so intense about
it if he wouldn't.
He didn't have the possibility of him
paying money right over his head.
I bet you he's obsessing right now.
He's mad right now.
He's mad.
Fuck.
He's like your skills broken broken
skills.
No.
Good.
Yeah.
He takes,
he thinks things are heavier than they
are or you think that skills bullshit.
They're lighter or heavier.
Something's wrong.
Fucking Rad.
He's just thinking about a way to get
out of it.
Right?
Absolutely.
Scrambling.
I mean we put a 35 pound weight on that
scale.
It was 35,
but not only that though,
he brought up the height thing to me,
I don't know,
a month or so ago,
and I had a long.
I was like,
look man,
we need to know what the goal weight
just is.
And he tweets.
He agreed it was 2:27,
27.
It was what?
It was a very,
very beginning.
Both way under that.
When I got here today,
I thought it would be 2:26 and
something.
You're almost 10 pounds under that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You are.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
So he lost.
Let's just talk about the beard now.
Are we shaping the whole thing off?
She gets.
You should make you aware it Hitler a
new state on the trip with already.
He's got to film a comedy Central Show,
right?
What is it on the eighth?
I gotta film Goddamn Jam on the
Eleventh,
January 11th,
and Ryan sickler has been fucking texted
me.
He's like,
you got this man,
don't let,
don't come on this show without a beard.
Oh yeah,
you're fucked.
You want to hear something crazy?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
so
this song,
Bert Kreischer and everyone's like,
which one
you've had beards and not beards since
I've known you.
Like when I first met you,
you didn't have a beard.
I just had stubble.
Yeah,
yeah.
When did you go full beard?
Probably when I got fatter.
But doesn't that make your face look
even bigger?
It does actually.
It does weight.
If it gets real bushy,
you definitely.
Even if you're fat,
it does.
It looks better.
And then you trim it and you're like,
oh,
it looks like I lost 20 pounds.
I went full beard when this Guy Evan
Tanner died,
get that guy who.
That's the saddest part of this whole
thing is tom used to be hot.
He used to look at push.
She looks great.
That's a different gal.
Was take the police shit.
She got paid to take a picture of
Christ.
You're closing in on that though,
Dude.
That's probably will never see that
again.
Bullshit never goes away.
It is.
Maybe 25.
How big.
How big do you think you were there in
[inaudible]?
Ninety five.
You know what?
Honestly,
your shoulders are bigger now.
Like,
Oh,
you've been lifting weight.
You actually stronger.
Bigger.
Um,
yes.
Young,
young man right there.
Wow.
How old are you there?
Twenty one or 22.
Wow.
That's actually how I,
that's me.
The same year I came to La,
so I came here with like their dreams
and your eyes.
Oh my God.
So many dreams.
Can you imagine if it said,
hey,
get fat.
You'll get famous.
Get Fat as fuck me,
Mike Tyson and you'll give.
You didn't have to be fat to be famous.
You know?
I remember Kevin James had this manager.
It's terrible manager.
At one point in time,
Kevin was trying to lose weight and his
manager was just a fucking idiot.
He said,
Kevin,
don't do it.
When you're losing weight,
you're losing roles.
Yeah.
It was like telling him roles in movies
and shit and they will tell me that
don't lose weight.
You won't be funding anymore.
So one of the dumbest things that you
can say,
well that's the people have this idea
that you can't be fit and be funny.
It's so stupid.
Yeah.
And then I heard someone say,
name a name,
fat comments aren't funny.
I was like,
what?
Oh,
that's ridiculous.
Venison.
Yeah.
Funniest of all time.
Is that as fuck?
Find a picture when Jamie.
See if you can go on my instagram and
see the picture of when I was skinny.
This is gonna.
You've ever seen this?
Like half?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Fucking different.
Real different either.
I haven't had.
I've had a beard.
My daughter's have never seen me without
a beard.
Well,
by the way,
if I lose,
my son is going to be terrified.
You know,
if I come home to.
That happened to me when my daughter was
really little.
I had a full crazy beard because this
guy,
Evan Tanner was a former UFC
middleweight champion.
He died.
He had this big beard,
so a bunch of us online,
bunch of fans decided to grow a beard
for Evan and I grew a fucking werewolf
beard,
like a full on know if you've ever seen
me
out into the forest,
but look at Youtube.
Beautiful guys are great there.
Yeah.
What year is this?
You had a goatee,
burke.
You have six,
right?
It's got to be.
Oh,
four.
Oh four.
That was for you.
We performed with the porn stars that
night.
What'd you guys at?
That's not me.
You and Nick Thune perform with the porn
stars that I'm certain of it.
See if you can find one with me with my
beard.
I miss it sometimes.
It was glorious.
It was big,
thick.
Fucking bushy,
crazy beard.
My daughters will lose their shit.
So what happened was I shaved my beard
off and my daughter didn't see me
shaving the beard off and she started
crying looking at me.
Yeah.
I had a full on beard son.
That was when I was living in Colorado.
I trimmed this,
trimmed it down because if I don't trim
it down,
it goes all the way up to two or,
you know,
just to look,
just look,
it just looks like I'm.
Because of the beard.
Yeah.
See,
right there.
You could see it.
God Dang.
Yeah.
They thinking about bread,
bread,
bread.
Yeah.
Um,
it's um,
it's a manly thing,
right?
Having a beard is a fucking manly.
Yeah.
Then you get like,
you just get used to it and then,
you know,
I would put lotion in it to smooth it
out.
Do that.
Uh,
no.
I have a rash inside my beard.
So if I lose my beard,
uh,
we're going to get to see what a
Vietnamese children's hands
look like.
Look at that picture.
That's a ridiculous picture.
Look at you.
You look like you're a little cute
little blue eyed baby.
When we were walking through the forest
in Vietnam,
we walked on this village and these kids
had never seen a dude with a beard
before because in Vietnam it'll grow
beards and they'd never been out of the
jungle.
And so we walked in and I came in with a
beard and they fucking lost their shit.
Thought I was a werewolf.
A million fucking around.
Yeah.
They lost her shit and they ran in
hothead.
I've never had that reaction with kids.
I'm always really good with kids.
And so I was like,
what's wrong?
And Tt was our,
our fixer.
And he's like,
your beard scares them.
They think you're a wolf.
And I said,
Oh,
let me tell them I'm okay.
So we brought a guitar over and we sat
with these kids and they wouldn't stop
looking at my beard.
So I go into my bag and I had had
skittles and m and m's with me.
So I pulled out skittles,
they'd never had fucking skittles and
give him skittles.
Nate's light up.
And then one of the kids is like,
it says in Vietnamese can play in your
face.
So I said,
sure.
So then all the kids started playing in
my face.
One kid had this funky hand and I was
like,
I was like,
this isn't going to go good.
And he gets in my head on,
as soon as he does it,
I feel everything get hot on my side.
I'm like,
oh,
I couldn't say anything.
And then it was on his hand,
I don't know,
just fucking disgusting.
Like he had never washed his hand.
And uh,
and so I've,
I've had this like thing that I've been
putting cortisone on for the last month,
trying to get it to go away.
And Katelyn,
I lose my beard.
Dermatologist.
No,
because I'm a beard.
No one saw it so I didn't give a fuck.
I hope so.
It's thing for a month.
How long?
Year and a half.
Jesus Christ Burns.
Go to a doctor.
I had a beard.
It's like if you get a pimple and a
beard,
you're like,
yeah,
fuck it.
You forget about it.
That's some crazy shit growing on
your face,
please,
please let it be.
Please let it.
My wife's been saying to me,
she's like,
you need to shave your beard and let it
air out because it's just that,
you know,
you sleep on your cheek.
And so it gets warm every night.
And it's like,
so yeah man,
whatever the fuck it is,
it's supposed to go away by now.
You should go to a doctor.
I'm not the doctor type.
But what time are we weighing in
tomorrow?
That's why I think we didn't know.
What time would you want to do tomorrow?
What time works for them?
Me.
Same time I'm getting,
but we're getting fucked up tomorrow
too.
Okay.
So what,
what kind of boots do you.
Mom will bring to Tito's and soda and
will bring pizza.
Cheetos.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Tito's and soda to.
What's the Tito Tito's vodka?
Vodka.
I don't know.
Shit.
I think they're Austin based,
right?
They're Austin based.
And uh,
the guy's name is Bert.
The owner of the company is named for
you to get some of that and we'll
actually eats us.
So we'll take an order at the end of the
day.
They are a pizza you want?
No,
no,
they're their team.
Burt's.
Let's do grey goose and sodas instead.
Ah,
we'll do team.
We'll do a Tito's and Greg,
you're a grey goose guy.
Grandiose.
And so I am since they went and burt
went,
team Burlington contacted you.
That hit me up.
They're like,
love the weight loss team.
Burton.
Yeah.
I had a bottle but I poured that shit
down to Jack Daniels is team Rogan.
If you want to hop on board list that
want to go jack and coke?
I'll do.
I haven't had that in forever.
I'll,
I'll join it on it.
Okay.
All right.
Jack and cokes tomorrow.
We're gonna get.
We're gonna get loopy.
Really fucked up tomorrow.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I've got to catch you up.
Do you want Dan super subs?
No,
no,
no.
I've been thinking about this for a
fucking bully.
Okay.
Can we get.
Can we get a pizza and hot wings?
Oh yeah,
for sure.
The only problem is getting it here at
11:00 AM.
How many pizza places are open at 10?
They're open.
They're open pretty early just for
slobs.
Pizza.
Pizza for breakfast.
Okay.
Can we get some thin crust,
Pepperoni,
whatever the fuck you want.
We'll take an order.
Will take an order and we'll bring it
in.
We should also do a,
uh,
a post binge wait,
see what we get up to.
Yeah,
we should,
we should go hard.
Go hard and figure it out.
Alright,
I'll,
I'll even eat pizza tomorrow.
So,
um,
that's going to be hard.
The weird part about this way and shit
is it's kind of fucked with my head a
little bit like in that I can
understand.
I'm not saying I understand,
but I understand what like anorexics the
control part of it,
you know,
like,
uh,
I don't,
I think I get the control part where you
go,
I'm not eating anything.
And then you feel you're in control.
You're like eating an apple and like,
oh I shouldn't have had that.
That's a lot of sugar.
I'm like,
well maybe I should throw that up.
Like I understand that part because I
bet tomorrow that first piece of pizza
is going to be very hard for me to eat
because I haven't had anything.
I've had a lot of anxiety over this.
Over what?
I had dreams last night that Bernie Shaw
was running me through fucking training
camp.
Really?
Dude.
Yeah.
Like I had a hundred dreams about Bernie
shop last night I dreamt that I put
Justin Bieber in the beat
the shit out of him.
Yeah.
Would you beat them with.
I beat him with my hands,
but then I slammed his head against the
floor or what caused the anger?
He said something about he's like nice
jacket at a diner and I go,
thanks.
I like your hair.
And he's like,
what'd you say to me?
And as soon as he said that I jumped
over the thing and I like elbowed him in
the face and took them and start
slamming his head against the wall and
then it just cut to,
in my dream it just cut to me walking
out of a jail and there was tmz there
and they're like,
why did you attack him when it was just
a big misunderstanding like,
uh,
like people say after like street
fights,
you know,
like it was just understanding that.
And then I dropped that was a going in a
car and people were following me and
they're like,
you shouldn't have attacked that guy.
Don't know if I woke up.
That's a lyric.
What's the biggest thing you've cheated
on this whole?
What's the one splurge?
We were like,
fuck it.
I can tell you mine right now.
He's had nothing but water.
No food wise.
Food Wise.
But for drinking,
he had,
it was coffee and water out there with
water.
Yeah.
And then I.
and then I cut coffee.
Coffee to 19 billion cups of coffee
today.
You did today.
Do that today.
I had to get on the treadmill.
Yeah.
But you don't have to have the coffee to
get on the treadmill.
Does.
I needed that.
Now it's song number two by blurted.
Get the day started.
It was the cup of coffee like the big
ones.
Do you know that's probably like eight
ounces.
You probably drank a pound of coffee.
Watch out.
That might've been the difference
tomorrow.
Just have a fucking.
I'll just do a little bump of coke.
There'll be fucking do.
Have you ever worked out on coke?
Have you?
And you fucking kill it.
Really?
I used to play basketball,
uh,
after smoking weed,
like pickup games in college.
And when I first got out here,
I took some of the best pickup games I
ever played was just like,
well nba players are famous,
you know,
they,
there was in the contract or a whole
one.
But yeah,
the whole Mba suite.
It's amazing.
Like if you've viewed,
dialed in,
I mean I imagine it might be like that
with Jujitsu in it is 100 percent like
that,
which you're dialed in on in basketball.
If you're like me,
you can lose yourself and like see plays
before,
you know,
see somebody hitting the whole before it
happens.
You start,
you get in the zone and you're just
zoned in on it.
Man,
I probably,
I probably spot on Jujitsu thousands of
times.
Really thousands,
like no bullshit over the course of 20
years.
I probably can.
Yeah.
Many,
many,
many times.
Smoked and then done Jujitsu many times
because everybody does it.
It's like one of these dudes would meet
at 10th planet.
We'd meet in the parking lot and get lit
up and then go in there and wrote it.
How high?
Like fuck.
Oh you get really low.
High.
Forget what I'm talking about.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
But
like you can't learn anything on high
when you're highlight that you don't
learn shit.
You just do,
you,
you're super creative.
Like,
like uh,
it's not good at someone's trying to
teach you something,
but what it is good for is if you
already know things,
you already know things and you just get
loose and zoned out and then he could
just,
you feel the moves better.
You feel like the attacks better.
No.
I know you've probably already talked
about this,
but I haven't heard you talk about it
real quick.
What about the Ronda Rousey thing?
Crazy fight.
I'm not good.
Not Good.
Oh,
it was.
You could see the panic.
He could see the anxiety.
You could see the difference in the
skill level striking wise.
Like I just think the whole,
there was a lot wrong with her camp.
A lot wrong with her preparation of lot
wrong with her mindset and a lot wrong
with our skillset in comparison to that
woman.
Amanda Nunez is a fucking monster.
She's a monster.
I knew that like a long time ago,
I was,
I thought she was the biggest threat to
Rhonda before Rhonda got knocked out by
Holly.
I was like,
I think Amanda Nunez is the biggest
threat because every fight start
standing and holly is a very good
striker,
but the real danger for holly I always
thought was her kicks in.
That's what she knocked out with a head
kick.
But like it kicks her harder to lay your
head kicks heartland that a punch when
in exchanges Rhonda would get punched,
you know,
and I'd seen her get punched by Meesha
and other people had punched her.
I'm like,
if fucking Amanda Nunez punches her,
she's gonna,
she's gonna get fucked up.
And that's exactly what happened.
But it was way worse because she was
still recovering psychologically from
that Holly Holm fight.
And then also physiologically when you
get head kicked,
we were talking about on the podcast
podcast yesterday,
there's some people that get head kicked
and they are never the same again.
Like never.
You never know.
Some people get a head injury and
they're okay.
A few months later,
some people get a head injury and
they're never the same.
The same person who you were goes away.
A person,
any head injury,
do that.
You know,
and I know someone from minute.
It was in an accident.
Nothing to do with fighting head trauma.
Never the same.
Well,
you know,
that's the Sam kinison story.
Sam kinison was one person and then he
got hit by a truck I think when he was a
little kid and was never the same again.
And then also he was just reckless
fucking wild man.
He was like,
this calm collected kid.
Normal kid kinda shy,
gets hit by a fucking truck and then all
of a sudden he's just wild man.
It doesn't give a fuck.
Is taking crazy chances and risks.
Wow.
You know,
I had a serious head injury.
There you go.
For crusher.
Thrown on my head in college and a fight
and knocked unconscious and then was out
of it and wandering around the campus
last didn't know who I was,
didn't know where it was.
Nobody brought you to a doctor.
This girl did this girl did.
Scott found me on campus and I was
confused.
I didn't know where I was.
And then she,
uh,
it was if I was in the middle of the day
while I was in a fraternity,
I had written a song about a.
and I did,
I had sung before and I guess he had
been upset before and told me that I
just didn't understand it.
So that's a problem with me is sometimes
I cast the big wake and I don't get that
I'm upsetting people that everyone's
having a good time and they feel like
I'm making fun of them,
but I'm not,
I'm just being fun,
stay the same,
you know?
And he came up to me in the middle of
the day and he was,
I was Solomon,
we were really good friends and he was,
he was big and he was like,
stay the fuck away from me.
And I thought he was kidding around and
I went up to him and he was like,
I'm fucking serious.
And he's like,
got in my face.
I was like,
are you,
are you really going to fucking hit me?
We're friends.
And He fucking grabbed me and tried to
and then literally like Suplex me and
flip flop me on my head and I went out
and I woke up and he was holding my
tongue so I swallowed my tongue.
He was holding my tongue out of my mouth
and he was crying and he was like,
I'm so sorry.
And I didn't know what happened.
And I just walked around.
I started walking around campus.
This girl found me a in the middle of
like and then drove me.
She drove me to the hospital and I was
in the hospital.
I was so confused.
I didn't know anything.
I didn't know who the president was and
I kind of started like coming,
figuring it out.
And then,
um,
and then my girlfriend and my best
friend came out and got me and took me
home.
But like,
for like a week I'd go like,
I remember one time I went to go get the
mail with my dog and I forgot where our
apartment was.
And I was like,
where the fuck is our apartment mate?
Did you see the guy again?
And he graduated that,
he was older than me.
He graduated that year and he came back,
oddly enough,
he came back and he tried to apologize
and I was just like,
I was like,
I dunno,
I'll never see you again.
You can go fuck yourself.
I felt so guilty about beating up Justin
Bieber in my dream and I downloaded two
of his songs after I woke up.
Which ones?
Cause he's got two really good ones.
I think it was like this,
sorry.
One and the uh,
the other big hit from last year or
whatever it was.
The one that Michael Chasing or not
Michael j.
The uh,
the other black guy from snl.
A,
I don't know.
Fucking Jay Pharaoh.
Oh,
that's racist.
I didn't mean that you guys,
but you.
But you're both black guys on snl.
I've seen a ton of people get hit in the
head.
I've probably seen more people get
knocked the fuck out.
Then I would say the.
Then one percent of all the living
humans that have ever lived.
Probably.
Yeah,
probably.
most likely.
Yeah.
It scares me.
Head injury scare me more than anything
because it just don't,
you don't know the scariest part.
Nice.
When I watch boxing or MMA,
even like the recap afterwards is when
you see it obviously different in slow
mo or afterwards,
but when you see that,
that that knockout blow has been landed
and fighters so zone zoned in on what
he's doing that he'll get in to more,
you know,
and,
and it's,
it's already like,
no,
like it's over and then you'll see like
another hit and,
and it's,
it's,
it's the lights were already off and you
see the whole head to go and then like a
second one is bouncing off the campus
and you're like,
my God.
And
then you know,
the ref even when,
if he's good jumps in and stops it,
but you're like,
that's,
that's way too much.
That's happened already.
There was a bad one this past weekend.
I'm Mike pyle fought this guy,
Alex Garcia,
and uh,
he got hit with a right hand and
dropped.
You got knocked out.
And then as one unconscious,
his head bounced off the canvas and the
head bounces are the scariest ones.
God goes out and then as he's fallen on
his head,
just a bang and when he got up he was
out for a bit and then he woke up,
he did not know what happened and they
tried to tell him he got knocked out and
he's like,
no way,
and then he goes,
no fuck.
But then he kept saying what happened?
And he's like,
you got knocked out.
I was like,
no.
What happened?
That's,
that's real comment.
I've seen that many times when people
get knocked out.
Can you believe bingos recovery?
How is she doing now?
Doing Great.
She is.
She's back at the fun house.
Is She?
Yeah.
When
she.
They released her.
I mean it was,
it was,
it was.
It wasn't an easy path.
You haven't talked to doug about it.
Totally anonymous,
but you got to explain the story.
Bingo for her.
I know I'm not speaking out of school.
I think this is stuff all dog is shared,
but Bingo was having her 40th birthday
party I think,
and so we're sisters came out,
her parents were coming out,
everyone was coming out.
She started partying pretty hard.
I think she did too much coke.
She had a seizure,
which has happened before,
but she fell off a step and hit her head
and apparently she was bleeding out of
every orifice of her face and you know,
all they're all,
you know,
Doug's,
everything's a joke there,
but it wasn't.
And uh,
I was in the car with big J and doug
called and was like,
hey guys,
it's Doug Stan hope.
And Jay's like,
why?
What's up?
Doug's like,
I think Bingo is going to die.
I'm probably not going to make it to the
end of the world podcast.
And then we were like,
Whoa,
you could tell he was kind of out of
sorts at the pod.
He was just off.
He was like,
it felt uncomfortable.
He kept leaving,
you know,
and he was going to say who is,
he was a really audit out by the whole
thing.
Yeah,
he was,
he was really worked up and then I would
talk to him.
I,
every now and then I'll talk to doug
late night when we were both drinking
and uh,
we talked to,
I think we talked for like an hour,
45 minutes and he was just like,
it's,
you know,
it's not going to,
this isn't good,
this isn't how it's going to go.
And then all of a sudden one day they're
like,
hey,
she started responding and then they're
like,
hey,
she's talking,
she's playing the guitar.
Hey,
she's doing good.
We're going to have a swallow test and
if we can get the,
we're going to try to get her trait
because that was her problem is her
vocal chords were all fucked up.
And then they got her tray and then
they're like,
hey,
there's a trick.
A trick is where the tracheotomy,
where they put a hole in your throat so
that she doesn't have to use her,
her throat to breathe.
You can just breathe right from your
lungs to the air.
And so then they were like,
you know,
it's going to be some real,
real rehabilitation.
It's going to take awhile to get her
back to where she was the day of her
birthday party,
but everything seems to be tracking
really nicely.
I mean so much.
So Doug is doug at the date,
like a week before Bingo.
Atarax and Doug called me like late
night and he was like,
do you have $100,000 you can part with?
And I was like,
yeah,
why?
And he goes,
I gotta
I gotta I have a line on a cave in
Arizona I want to buy will get me,
you norm Mcdonald.
Joe will get us all in.
We're going to do it right.
And I was like,
hey dave,
but you haven't,
he hasn't texted you about this.
Well I know there's a house that's for
sale that's built into a cave.
Is that the one?
$2,000,000 is like 10 of us.
100 grand.
We just put it in and then we have our
own cave.
I don't want to go to that cave.
Well that's why we maybe as a texted you
and how's it been for sale for like a
decade.
And so and so.
Then he said he was going to ask for
medical bills.
Money.
No,
that makes sense.
And then last night or night before
last,
he started talking about the cave again.
So I go,
things must be doing good in the fun
house of Doug wants to go back to the
cave in Mcdonald's,
in Roseanne.
Barr's.
What are they going to do with this
case?
I don't know,
but I'm pot committed on a grand book in
my hands.
Like we're not buying a fucking kid.
You're 100 grand into a cave and he
doesn't want to part with a fucking
plane ticket to parents because he
thinks you're lying about your height.
He's,
he's gonna.
He's gonna.
Roll back every excuse tomorrow to get
rough.
You can tell them we're six,
four and he's.
He doesn't care.
I don't bullshit.
God Damn it.
I'll lose my fucking beard.
I think.
Well,
he's very frugal.
Yeah,
he is.
Oh,
except the reason are going to give away
money.
You were hearing them on that podcast.
He was like,
oh,
well I need.
You just went like cool things.
So if you have an idea,
I mean maybe I'll fund it.
So really?
Yeah.
He's like,
I have everything I need.
What ideas would you want to fund?
Like how good would the idea have to be
before that?
Like I'm like,
just take this be insanely good.
Yeah.
I don't know if it's like just a
creative project.
People have come up to me with some
really good ideas and I'm like,
good luck.
I'm not fun and Shit.
Yeah,
I don't it ever excite,
you know?
I don't want to think.
Yeah,
I don't want to.
Here's the thing,
people go,
it won't be a big deal.
You just give me my,
I'm going to handle it now you know,
I'm going to think about it cost me
money.
I would rather have less money and not
think about you doing that.
Then to make money from you doing that
because then I have to think like as
soon as you start,
you complicate your life when you get
involved in too many endeavors.
I'm already involved in too much shit as
it is,
but when I say that to people,
they go,
you're not ever going to stop.
You still get a lot of pitches all the
time.
I was with you for it.
What was that?
Good into it?
We were a member.
A guy met us.
Uh,
it was arranged and we were in New York
or something.
He was at the restaurant.
He was like,
I've built like a this city.
Yeah.
And the mountain in the mountains.
And I was there like,
what I'm trying to start selling right
now,
community in the mountain.
And then he was like,
and here's this.
It's like people like you because we'd
like to just have you up there and um,
you know,
on the house,
of course we'll take care of you.
Your whole family can go and enjoy it.
And I'm like,
yeah.
So,
so that later he buys it like you,
you're giving them a week free and then
now do you want to buy it?
Yeah.
And he's like trying to say like,
Nah,
I just want you to enjoy it.
Like so he can buy it,
I think you're going to let him stay
there and
then the more you use me to try to rope
other people in the buying their.
Yeah,
I mean it was fine.
I mean,
you know,
the concentrator community,
that's his pitch,
but communities get constructed
naturally.
Yeah.
I've never heard.
I mean,
I guess it was an upscale community.
Do you remember when you wanted to buy
it,
when you wanted to make a compound up in
Santa Barbara?
Still do.
By the way,
that's what land yesterday.
Santa Barbara everywhere.
I love Santa Barbara trying to get off
the grid son.
Leanne and I are looking at property in
Colorado where right now we're at a
place where our,
our payments are.
Leanne set it up so that we can be,
we could be poor.
Pay Off your house.
You have your mood stove with a
mortgage.
We've been talking about Colorado.
You want to buy a house together?
We're in Colorado.
Um,
I like to.
I personally,
I would like to stay no more than 45 to
an hour outside of Denver.
Evergreen,
but up in the,
up,
up like above the,
above the elevation,
like 7,500 feet.
You've been evergreen?
No.
Yes.
Evergreens.
A spot where my buddy lives.
They're fucking amazing.
You got to put like a bear like nails up
upside down so the bears don't come in
your fucking house.
You do have to do that sometimes and
they have certain kinds of door knobs.
Like they don't,
they,
you know,
those door knobs that are like,
uh,
like pulled down door knobs.
They don't recommend those bears figure
those fuckers out and they figured out
how to do.
Let's get a house together.
You want to do that?
You guys go on gay for each other.
Look at this.
This will be.
Oh,
this is my dream to bears with bears
like burke.
Are you really looking at that?
Yeah.
We've talked about yesterday because you
can get it fairly cheap up there.
Especially if we go halvsies.
Alright.
It's hard to do have to mortgage.
Yeah.
Not knowing even where to start a
corporation.
A evergreen is fucking beautiful.
It's my favorite.
I think my favorite city to go to
Denver.
I love them.
This is the shit.
Yeah,
my sound guy lives up there.
Those people got it made man.
I mean they're,
they're staring at the rocky mountains
everyday.
Weed's legal,
real estate prices are through the roof.
Everyone was cool.
They're so cool.
We're getting so high tomorrow.
Yeah.
Tomorrow.
So,
um,
how are you guys going to deal with the
rest of the day?
Do you just get out of here and just
start running?
Like what are you going to do is get on
the treadmill?
I gotta go,
you gotTa.
Go do my horse.
I've got to do one with Joey now.
Is there any concern about the rest of
the day?
Like,
you know,
this is like,
it's a race that you've.
You're ahead.
Yeah.
But you've got to be careful with 32
ounces.
Oh,
I got to be real careful today.
Look,
Tom.
Tom,
tom is Derek jeter on Mickey Mantle.
He keeps saying this.
Mickey Mantle is Mickey.
Mantle was a fucking savage.
Wasn't fucking party this whole fucking
life.
Never show up to a game.
Fucking half sober and stills wondering
who.
Do you remember more,
Tom?
Be Honest.
Mickey mantle or Derek Jeter to steal
from Daniel Tosh.
Just like train wreck stole from Daniel
Tosh.
I'm trainwreck.
Stole
from Daniel.
Yeah.
They did a movie here.
They did.
Fuck.
Yeah,
they did.
They directly stole one of his lines.
Really?
Yeah.
He had a bit about Babe Ruth.
He's like,
yeah.
He goes,
it should be an asterisk next to his
name because he never had to play
against black eyes talking about babe
ruth never took steroids.
He also never played against black guys
in.
Daniel tosh had a great bit.
They stole it.
I fucking hate him.
And that tell you this.
He did it on a show I want to show you
talked about it on the show and there's
a one of the compilations of plagiarism
accusations against Schumer.
Has that in there.
Wow.
Yeah.
Has a lot.
By the way,
there's a lot.
There's a new video that's out.
There's a lot.
It gets hairy where you gotta go.
All righty.
Anyway,
Mickey Mantle didn't play against black
guys.
Or did he make you mantle play against
black guy?
Jackie Robinson.
Well,
before him.
So you're saying that you're just the
gunslinger,
but like what you're going to do?
I can already predict tomorrow.
Oh,
Tommy's going to come in at 2:17,
2:15?
No,
Tommy's going to be about 2:15.
Yay.
Is Tom's.
Tom has hit his threshold weight.
Still eating chicken.
I'm not eating anything.
Right,
right.
Probably drank seven pounds of water.
And you got to understand that like
you're a hold on to more water.
You either one of you guys fucked with
distilled water.
That's all I'd been drinking.
You can't drink too much of that because
it will deplete your body of minerals
and electrolytes.
Yeah.
Why I didn't look.
I just.
All I know is that I can run.
I can probably run 20 miles between now
and then.
That's all I need.
Sort of.
The problem is you.
Boy,
when are you going to do it?
Like when are you going to actually do
it?
Because you literally have to do it
before the wind.
You can't,
you're not gonna be able to drink
anything.
Like you have think about like 32
ounces.
This is what?
Eight ounces?
16.
These are 16.
These are 32 is right here.
Six to 16 point nine.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Okay.
So two of these,
two of these,
two of these.
He's ahead of you.
Just to have these so you can't fuck
around.
I don't,
I don't use math in this.
I use heart long string DNA Strand Dna
Strand Dna was that movie that I saw.
You think you just.
If you just do the run then you'll,
you'll do it.
I'm not going to eat anything either.
You got to feel like shit.
Nope.
No,
I'm different than you guys.
I got.
I've got that long strand DNA.
You're different.
How are you different than the focus on
it?
I focus like I get,
I get hyper aware and I go.
I have a goal.
Like today when I woke up I wanted a
glass of water so bad it was stick for
him.
Those guys are hilarious.
That.
Yeah,
it's my mentality.
Dan,
you know how many fucking dummies I've
met?
Tell me they could fight in the UFC.
I know I could beat anybody.
It's because my mentality,
she was
head kick and fight someone.
Sorry.
We cheat,
he'll,
we fight Sam pond balls.
Cm punk will beat the fuck out of the
both of you guys.
Of course he might have gotten his ass
kicked by Micky Gall,
but micky gall is a real fighter.
Let's be clear here.
Bert said that.
Leave me out of this.
You don't think cm punk will beat your
ass?
Dude,
I don't know enough.
I'm just joking.
I don't fucking know anything about cm
punk.
I've never knew him when he was a famous
that we should fight,
right?
Yeah.
Let's fight.
No,
not owen fight you.
Let's see.
We can gain the most weight next.
Oh No,
no,
no.
You guys gotta.
See this gotta be like the new,
you know,
can you make this happen though?
Like what are you thinking after?
This is over six months.
That's what if we weighed in April first
and July first,
so three months and then six months.
Well,
here's the thing.
This is the right way to do it.
And you and I talked about this.
The right way to do this is you have a
way in every 12 weeks or every,
uh,
every month for 12 months,
every four weeks,
and at the end of the year you tally up
a score,
like a race to 12,
like see who wins each month.
So the only way to,
to really do it would be like you would
have to actually lose body weight.
You couldn't just dehydrate yourself
every month and go under because if one
of you keeps going,
like say if you guys had to do it,
like if I was in on the challenge and
you guys have to do it against me,
I'm 19 pounds lighter than the heaviest
or other than the lightest guy right
now.
So I would already have an advantage.
So if I just started losing more and
more weight,
you would have to lose body weight in
order to be in the race.
You can't just lose 19 pounds of body
weight every month like that.
You wouldn't be able to do it.
So if you started today and then every
month you guys had a way in challenge,
the number would drop every month.
Like it's two,
19 now,
next month.
Probably like two.
Oh,
seven next month it would be like to,
you know,
a tool one and then you would keep going
and going and going until you guys were
skinny as fuck.
You guys will be like bodybuilders by
the end of the year?
I don't think.
I don't mean I,
I'm,
I'm not saying I'm sure I'd probably
love being what?
80 six really?
I mean,
I'm not saying I'm not,
I'm not,
I wasn't about to say that.
I was going to say sure,
I'd love it.
But personally I think to fifteens a
really great weight for me.
I know it's still overweight,
but like you,
but you don't want to be overweight.
Right?
I don't want to be overweight,
but I also don't want to look.
I don't want to look like this.
I'd,
well I'd love to be fucking yoked,
but I don't know if I have the fucking.
I like crossfit.
I've been doing crossfit,
see it,
and I had to stop because I was afraid I
was building up too much mass because
you're putting on too much weight.
I was like,
this is a weight loss challenge.
Any weight that comes in and muscle I
don't want.
I'm just going to run my actually can
ask about the same thing.
I,
like I said,
I've always,
you know,
done weightlifting at my heaviest and
like six,
eight weeks ago I was like,
oh,
I fucking,
I haven't done.
It feels weird.
I
actually feel,
feel somewhat like different that I
haven't touched weights.
Yeah,
I mean it makes a big difference and
then the only way to keep the weight off
while you're doing that you'd have to do
like lightweight,
low reps,
but you're still a weight high reps,
right?
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
Light,
lightweight high reps.
yeah.
Yeah.
And I thought about that and I know some
people are going to tell them like
that's what you should have done.
You would allow us more,
but I kind of just pick the fuck anyone
with any insights or weight loss.
It's a pedestrian like I hate when they
go.
Listen,
man,
if you're not eating a lot of calories,
your body is going to backfire.
Start storing fat.
Fuck you.
Tell that to the kids in Ethiopia.
Well,
if you don't eat your fucking lose.
Fucking wait.
That's how that fucking works.
If you burn more calories than you take
in,
your body has a certain reaction and
that's how that fucking works.
He's done in a scientific route that
he's put his body into a state of
ketosis.
He's cut out all the sugar and the carbs
and now his body's burning fat.
I think I might've done that too,
except for the vodka sodas.
Yeah,
they'll.
They'll stop you from really getting
into ketosis of the alcohol will do.
You have one of those sticks.
You can piss on a stick sticks.
Yeah.
This stuff is key.
Jenny.
This is exogenous ketones.
You take this stuff,
it puts you into like you could drink a
fucking Dr Pepper and then you take this
stuff and it'll put you into a state
where your body is burning fat,
not carbohydrates.
Hold on.
You're telling me if I put that in a
vodka soda,
it was just immediately burning that
sugar telling.
If you take a vodka soda and then take
this afterwards,
I wouldn't mix the two of them together.
I don't think that's smart,
but drink this afterwards.
You're back on track.
Oh,
you do?
Yeah,
you can get right back on track.
for sure.
Until the company to hit me up.
Yeah.
No,
they're not going to
know we're doing for actual healthy
people
like you don't.
This is what,
where it's crazy.
It's like you're on the door to looking
great.
Like you're right there and you're
already ready to fucking go run back
into the woods.
You're like door.
You are.
It's your mindset is like this is
temporary,
but you guys have totally different
mindset.
Your mindset is
definitely starve yourself.
Go at it like a fucking savage.
I mean,
look you,
you had gloves.
You came in here with gloves for your
hands.
Could sweat.
You have your gloves here.
Maniac.
And then Tom is.
I did two miles yesterday,
man.
That's it.
You know,
two miles.
Two miles in the coliseum.
Yeah.
So there's a totally different mindsets.
Yours is like extreme short term,
but unsustainable.
Everything he's doing is totally
sustainable.
Yeah.
I'm curious to see what it would be
like.
My body had 2000 calories a day,
but what all that.
You can do that,
but you like when you get down to a
certain weight,
you don't want that because then your
body's gonna start eating it's muscle.
That's what happens when your body gets
to a certain stages.
We have to understand about losing
weight.
If you,
if your body doesn't have the amount of
protein that it needs,
you start consuming your own muscle.
I've
been eating.
I've been eating proteins and greens.
That's it.
That's good.
No carbs,
no breads,
no pastas.
Beans is the only carb I've had.
I've only had that twice in a month.
You can up that a little bit.
Yeah,
but when you think about like,
I'm going to be,
you know,
I'm only going to take in 2000 calories
a day.
I want to do this.
You will lose weight,
but you also lose strength.
You feel exhausted.
Your body starts.
I had that dinner last night,
that big dinner last night,
and when I go on the treadmill I felt
fucking phenomenal like I got on there
and literally it was like 10 miles or
seven miles.
No rush of energy,
sugar,
everything from that.
Yeah,
but that might have fucked you.
You might've been two pounds lighter if
you didn't do that.
No Shit.
He might do it to the impulse.
Yeah,
and I noticed that that was my bed,
so I was betting on that.
Yeah,
that's the bet was he was saying that
you are just going to wait until the
last minute and go crazy.
That's exactly what Graham and I said
that by the way a month ago I knew that
you were going to do,
but if you're disciplined wasn't on
point and he still would have.
Got You.
That's true.
We got down to two of these fucking
things,
two little bottles of water,
which is pretty amazing.
Yeah.
So you have to win tomorrow.
If to win,
you have to be two and a half pounds or
more.
Less than me.
Yeah.
So you might be able to lose even more,
like if you go fucking crazy today and
you'd go Bert Kreischer.
So the thing is you guys have narrowed
it down,
this victory is down to 24 hours or less
now.
But if you go fucking crazy and go full
bird all day today,
[inaudible],
he's almost like you can't catch it.
He doesn't,
he doesn't have that gene.
But what is that long Strand Dna,
Mickey Mantle genes.
Nonsense gene.
This,
this is just discipline.
It's the thing like,
like I've thought about this a lot.
The thing that makes this contest
interesting is also the reason we like
each other because he is very even
keeled and I am fucking all over the
map.
I have a combination of the.
Both of you guys,
but you definitely.
You have,
you have,
you have the same brain I have about
like the way you shoot bows and arrows
and you're like,
that's right.
I'll just do that for three hours until
I need maybe need shoulder surgery.
You know like,
and,
or the way you shoot pool.
Like you're very,
like,
you get obsessed with things,
you're like,
that's why I can't fuck with drawing
anymore because I get obsessed with it.
I get like that.
Tom.
So even killed,
like the perfect example of our
relationship is that first day we were
in Hawaii and I shaved your tits.
Yeah.
And it is the funniest Joe.
It is the funniest fucking thing I've
ever been a part of my life.
And he goes to Hawaii and he's like,
and he's out there.
I go,
Oh man,
you know Tom's hair.
I go,
hey,
why don't I shave your back for you?
And he was like,
you think?
Yeah.
And so I started.
I started to put the volume on this.
This is just,
Oh,
don't put the volume.
You can hear music on it and friends,
Charlie and Laurel stand by and support
and your shaving Tom's back.
I'm shaving his back and then at some
point in this,
and you can just skip ahead at some
I realized that Tom's tit hair connects
with his underarm hair and I go,
hey buddy.
Wanting to hear a pause right there.
I realized I go,
Hey man,
let me hollow that out for you.
I go,
you know what I'll do is I'll trim out
contour,
contour it and make your,
make it so your tid has defined hair and
you're under on has defined here,
but they're not connected like a
werewolf and then I'll seize her out
your breasts,
like I'll do a seasonal comin down and
align it up so it looks like you're
defined and he sold it like real serious
and by the way,
you've got to
Tom's ernest face staring at me as I do
this and I'm close to it and I'm looking
at him and I'm trimming it.
And then as I pulled back I still see
Tom's earnest face going,
does it look good?
And all I see it looks like his tits are
wearing sunglasses and then I realized
this
first of like seven days in Hawaii and
he's got to look like this the whole
fucking time.
And I never seen him laugh.
I thought I was having a stroke.
You have less body hair back then?
Yeah.
I know you've gained body hair as you
got older.
That's even weirder.
What year is this?
Oh,
a
gain.
So much body hair in eight years.
I don't know.
It's weird
looking serious.
Tom Is looking all serious.
Thomas,
are you gonna?
Watch me watch it looks terrible
because it makes her look bigger.
You shaved my head,
shaved under it.
But you left the hair above it.
So it's like you have like breastplates.
Yeah,
it is the I've,
I've never laughed that hard in that
whole trip is probably me.
Tom and push and Leanne became friends.
Well that's what I knew we could be
friends
is because then our wives became good.
Yeah,
that is hilarious.
What you did.
That one looks normal.
So Tom,
what year did you come to la?
Oh,
two.
So in six years you put on all that
weight?
Yeah,
but I also,
I,
that's how I graduated high school and
went into college like that.
Weight and then I lost all that weight.
How'd you do that?
Diet and exercise.
Really?
Yeah.
And then what made you abandon it?
I,
it was slow.
It was a slow crawl like I got here.
I remember when I was working the night
shift at a post production place,
it was like all the sudden,
I mean it wasn't all of a sudden,
but like,
you know,
late night food,
really weird hours,
like staying up until four or 5:00 AM
doing the graveyard shift and then going
to bed and all of a sudden you're like,
I'm up to 25.
Oh Shit.
I thought it was two.
Oh five.
Like,
you know what I mean?
Like you put on 20 pounds over the
course of like a,
you know,
a couple of shows in production and then
you're not even thinking about it.
And then at that point to 25 rolls into
2:30 real easy,
you know,
it's just,
it's a slow thing.
But it took,
I would say I got here in 2002 by 2005.
I was 2:25.
Now you don't seem to be looking at the
same way he's looking at.
He's looking at it like this is like a
race.
You hit the finish line and then you
gorge and then the fucking is over.
You seem to be like adjusting your life.
Well I think,
I mean I definitely want to have a new
ceiling of what is,
you know,
an acceptable wait and,
and I,
I definitely feel like this is a very
livable way.
What I've been doing like for the last
few months.
I mean this last week is a little
crazier obviously,
but the last few,
the last month has been,
it hasn't been that difficult
to what?
Like how much weight have you been
losing a month?
Have you been noticing?
Yeah,
I mean this has been about 10 pounds.
Twelve pounds a month.
That's a lot.
But it's doable.
It's doable and it's not.
I'm not,
I'm not killing myself suffering to do
it.
Like I'm just on top of the eating and I
just,
I do.
I've been doing cardio about six days a
week.
Now if you get to a certain point,
are you,
what do you do?
Like are you going to like,
eat more?
Like what,
what?
What's the weight where you go,
okay.
I don't want to lose any more weight.
I think is less about the number.
Even though we get so obsessed with the
numbers,
right,
and like the way you feel about,
you know,
like,
right,
like it especially if you start lifting
weights again and you put on a little
bit weight,
your body fats lower.
Yeah.
So I mean like I'm trying not to be
obsessed with the number,
but I know like I would want to lose if
we were talking about the number,
like 15 to 20 more pounds,
which I think is really.
I think so.
I like to lose six pounds more.
I'd like to,
I'd like to get to 15 and then maintain
and eat healthy and eat clean.
Yeah.
But I also,
you know,
I mean I can't lie about this and say
this is a lifestyle like the people on
the biggest loser.
Legit.
I love,
I love fucking hot wings.
I love hot wings.
I love Buffalo Wild Wings and I love the
feeling of like,
like I remember I told you a long time
ago that my weight loss program was to
stop eating appetizers like advertisers.
I love when I make it rain appetizers.
I love that feeling and I,
I miss blimpie sandwiches,
I Miss Pizza.
My girls have been eaten pizza and I'm
eating cauliflower pizza,
which I like.
But what's cauliflower pizza?
Oh,
it's good.
You take a 12 ounces of cauliflower,
you steam it in the microwave for like
four minutes.
You dry it out,
you put one egg in there,
a third cup of Mozzarella that I'm like
a fourth cup of Parmesan and you put it
into a,
that's your crust and then you put it in
the oven.
It's,
every slice is very low calories because
it's cauliflower.
All really eating is like a portion
of an egg and some Mozzarella.
It's really fucking good.
Um,
I'll,
I'll make something if you wanted to
bring it in tomorrow and we can try it.
Yeah,
I'll try that.
I think after awhile though,
you.
I mean,
I don't miss that many things.
You know,
food wise,
the really hard thing for really is a
shift in the way you live the shift
shift.
What you think about.
I have a waffle date tomorrow with my
wife because we're having waffles going
to go.
I found a place that in the morning.
First thing in the morning.
Yeah,
right before the wind.
So wait.
So wait,
did you really didn't eat those cookies
at all?
Not,
not even.
I've been.
Oh,
I didn't even open the box.
Here's some cookies.
Discipline.
I send them cookies,
discipline,
Lewin's races,
impulse doesn't win.
Races a impulse.
Does those wins races.
It didn't win today.
I know,
but it definitely shocked.
Impulse impulses get results,
but they don't get the best results.
The best results are gone through
discipline.
My manager's got pissed about this whole
weight loss thing is I'm in the middle
of it scripted deal.
And uh,
I wasn't sending him scripts.
I was just fucking around with Tom.
And they're like,
they're like,
they call it the end.
They're like,
hey,
he needs to like take all your wife.
They're like,
back the fuck off of that.
They were like,
Hey,
what's Bert is like,
seems to be obsessed about this weight
loss thing.
Like we've got a TV show we're trying to
make like Atlanta,
like,
oh,
you don't understand burt,
like he will never work on this TV show.
If you don't,
if you don't respect the fact that this
is what he's focused on,
so what I was doing was I was,
I was setting up accounts.
It didn't work out right,
but I was setting up accounts at
different food places so they could,
that fans could send Tom Food and I was
like,
I wasted a whole day,
and then I sent him these cookies that
were amazing.
I sent him to my daughters.
They loved him and I said,
I'm from the rock to tom and tom didn't
even eat them.
He just gave him the fucking people
working on his brand new,
a $3,000,000 house,
but they're good cookies.
I want to try them when I get done.
You're already thinking about wings and
cookies and pizza and this and.
But I'm already thinking about.
I'm also thinking about the long Strand
Dna,
mickey mantle jeans I could find.
Anybody
got that mentality,
Bro.
I just can't lose.
I'm different.
Everybody wants to think they're
different,
but everybody does.
Everybody does.
Including the people that you think
you're different from,
they think they're different.
Yeah.
Everybody thinks they're different.
That's what gets people knocked the fuck
out.
That's Hashtag [inaudible] the return.
Yeah.
That's what that is.
No,
I'm not real.
That's like Ronda Rousey's idea was that
she's different than everybody.
You know,
everybody.
I'm the best in the world that people
love to have that and sometimes you win
and you really do feel like you are
that,
but the reality is you are a skeleton
and some fucking cells and you're run by
a central nervous system and your brain
has a whole bunch of defense mechanisms
that are designed to protect you from
reality.
And one of those is that it decides I'm
different in these motherfuckers.
Don't you fucking agree with them just
because you're sitting there,
but you know it's true.
I know that.
I know that's how you think
it is.
It's a real.
It's a problem.
I knew that he was really like,
I'm going to run 28 miles.
How many people,
how many people?
Especially beautiful girls,
how many beautiful girls just think
they're fucking special because we were
talking about that.
We were talking about that today,
about the um,
the,
the horror and the danger of daddy's
that especially that kind of,
you know,
push the princess ideal on their girls
and that make them think that they're so
special and then that girl kind of seeks
that out,
you know,
and he leaves that.
And then what are the type of guy that
does go for that?
Usually if he's romantically is
basically a paternal figure to that girl
who,
if he's going to still see her as a
princess,
you know,
princesses are weird.
It's a weird thing that everybody wants
to be a princess.
So weird.
And you see,
you start to see that it's fucked up.
I actually,
I remember being in high school and like
seeing girls who are like,
I'm the most special and you go like,
and I better respect that I'm the most
special.
Yeah.
If you don't,
someone will,
you're not going to find that guy.
Yeah.
And that'll be your second daddy.
I am more important than anything in
your life.
Yeah.
Period.
To carve out time for me.
You've had that speech,
Huh?
Oh yeah.
The carve out time for me speech.
I ran into a chick one time that I think
you'd had relations with.
How dare you.
Let's not even discuss it off the air.
I've had too many bad situations in my
life where someone thinks they're
special.
Yeah.
It gets.
It gets at a certain point in time.
You have to blame yourself for getting
involved with those people though.
Let's let's work this backwards.
Like I think Cameron Hanes,
the ability that he can run those ultra
marathons,
that's special.
He'd be able to.
If you meet that guy,
let me tell you something.
He would be the last person to call
them.
So special.
But.
But he's all discipline.
We could agree that him,
a guy like him or like conor Mcgregor.
Let me give me a cameron hanes speech.
Cameron Hanes was about 180 plus.
Okay.
Like lifting weights,
all that jazz.
And he wanted to run the 200 miles.
So what he did was he got down to 165
and the way he did it was burning 3000
calories,
eating 2000 calories.
So he never stopped working out,
he was running like a fucking maniac and
he led his body eat itself.
So he just got,
he just shrunk.
I got watched it happen and all the
sudden you'll just different like he
looks very,
very skinny but still a little.
He's getting more [inaudible],
needs a little thicker now,
put on a little bit more weight.
But when he was a running the 205 miles
when he ran that a big foot,
78 fucking hours run ran 200,
five miles.
I couldn't do that.
Exactly.
That's a discipline thing.
That's the difference between that long
strands.
People that think they're special and a
guy like him,
he doesn't think he's special at all.
He thinks the only thing about him that
separates him from everybody else's,
that he works
harder.
That's it.
But how does one do a hundred mile?
I mean like I don't even.
He's a maniac.
When you start a body break the fuck
down.
You talked about how he started off like
doing like 10 ks,
you know,
and then you know,
you feel like,
wow,
maybe I should do a marathon.
And then he started doing a marathon and
they do a marathon,
then we'll be,
I want to win a marathon.
And then you start,
he beat Lance Armstrong in the Boston
marathon.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
He's a fucking animal dude.
You know,
I did a 10 K on accident,
dude.
I went to a,
I went to Cincinnati
with all your bags off the plane and
everyone's running and you start running
with them.
And
I went to,
I went to Cincinnati for Thanksgiving
and Christmas this year.
It was a couple of years back and I got
there and most of my cousins are pretty
fit and they're like a,
hey,
we're doing the um,
just the day with like we're doing the,
a 10 k tomorrow.
And then we're um,
you know,
we'll regroup and then we'll come over
here and then we'll go over to this
aunt's house.
And I was like,
Oh yeah,
nick,
do you want to do it?
And I didn't have the,
um,
like just admit that I didn't know what
attendance list,
so I just said,
yeah,
I didn't realize what I was doing.
And I was like,
yeah,
I'll do that.
I showed up with zero point zero
training,
like nothing and I just go and I was
like,
how far is this?
And they're like,
it's about three point one miles.
And I was like,
Oh shit,
because I'm 250 pounds and I was like,
this is going to be bad.
Right.
And I just think is like,
the crowd helps,
you know,
because there's so many people.
There are stretches where there's
nobody.
Yeah,
there's stretches where there's nobody.
And the thing,
like,
I finished it and I was like,
wow,
that's,
you know,
I thought I felt like I ran two
marathons,
you know,
like it was so much further than I've
run since fucking middle school.
It's like six miles.
I think it was.
Okay.
Oh,
five case,
three one,
a 10K six.
Yes,
I did fucking six miles.
And,
and then it was that the next couple
days work the pains.
I've never like in the hips
and uh,
we tried to go to a movie like as a
family group and I couldn't sit.
I was like,
I got,
I gotta I gotta gladiator because the
pain was just like I couldn't move and
got to build up to me and full trauma.
It was a shock.
10 K meaningful trauma in Omaha and uh,
I get,
I go on,
I'm trying to be healthy and I go on
radio and I said,
I'm looking for a five k,
five k hit me up,
I'm going to run it this weekend.
And so this guy reaches out to me and
he's like,
Hey,
I got a brewery five k.
I was like,
right up my alley.
So I hit a full trial on Friday night
and he goes,
tomorrow morning we're running a
brewery,
five k in full.
Like what?
We run from brewery to brewery.
I go,
yeah,
you run brewery brewery.
It's like fucking,
it's like a bar.
It's like a bar crawl,
but you kill beers the whole time.
It's perfect.
Have like beers,
run a five
k go home,
take a nap,
do two shows,
this will be great.
My favorite part is that he goes,
perfect.
That sounds ideal to anybody.
Horrible
bull trout.
And I got there and uh,
and everyone's,
everyone's at the brewery and everyone's
drinking and we're like,
fuck it.
Let's start killing beers now.
It's like 10 in the morning races at
like noon.
So we start killing beers.
We have like five beers and then we're
like,
all right,
everyone line up and we'd line up.
We noticed that everyone's dressing like
hardcore sports gear and we're not.
We're like,
God damn it man.
They're really taking this serious.
And we're like,
what's the first bar we stopped at?
And they're like,
no bar.
It's a fucking five k.
and so full tron did.
And I did a five k drunk at like a noon.
And by the way,
we beat half of the fucking field.
She's drunk.
So the brewery,
the brewery,
it's,
that's where it started at the brewery
and it ended at the brewery.
It was a big circle to the brewery.
Did everybody else drink too?
No one drank except for us.
Everyone's like,
man,
you really putting them back.
We're like,
well I want to be apart of the team.
Well you were probably fueled up.
I mean that's.
There's a lot of calories in beer and is
also carbohydrates,
so all the barley and all that jazz
getting when they shoot the gun,
fuel race tells.
Don't people do that?
Runner known people after running.
Don't they like to drink beer for
recovery?
Absolutely don't think so.
They used to do it drinking beer for
recovery.
Post workout.
They used to do it in the,
in the,
in the Tour de France,
in the Tour de France.
They would stop and drink big heavy
beers and I would imagine there's like a
lot of calories in that,
but a lot of calories.
I think it would make you crash a little
bit though.
Like drain you.
I definitely feel like working out when
I'm drunk.
No.
Are you serious?
I've done it.
Wait,
tell us about coke working out.
I forgot about that.
That good.
Here we go to health benefits.
Here are a few reasons.
So after your run the health benefits of
beer,
make that a little larger please.
So I can get that.
Although most runners agree that beer is
not exactly a health food.
There is good news for those of us who
like to imbibe.
Downing a few cold ones as you're
heading out the door for a run is
obviously not the best choice,
but beer in moderation can be perfectly
acceptable.
Option for after a run or on non
training days.
And you go,
yeah,
I'm.
One of my favorite things doing is on
the road,
especially when I was working on travel
channel is going right back to the hotel
after dinner and after drinking and
getting into the,
into the gym and working out really a
legit.
I love getting on the treadmill with a
glass.
I've talked to you about this drunk
feels like to you.
I said I feel very different than what
it feels like everyone else.
Yeah.
And I had a conversation over the oddly
enough of the 10 year old yesterday
about being hung over.
So I guess let me tell you how it's
done.
He was like,
don't you feel sick?
I.
That's the other problem I have is I
don't really feel sick when I don't.
After I drank,
I don't get hung over good drunk by the
way.
I'm.
I'm like,
I don't think that's the other problem
is no one can ever tell him drunk.
I remember one time when we were in
Hawaii,
actually I remember specifically that he
had been drinking for like 15
hours and it was so many beers and,
and,
and then liquor and then beers and he's
in our room and I was like,
dude,
like how are you not,
you're okay.
He's like,
I'm fucking hammered.
I was like,
but you've looked fine.
He was like,
Oh,
I definitely not,
not even close to find right now,
but if he,
if he didn't tell me that,
I would not know.
My wife always says I can't.
I cannot tell when you've been drinking,
but it's every day.
No.
That's the other thing.
I think there's a lot of,
you know,
the,
the pump of what I am.
I think people think one thing I'm not.
How often do you drink booze days?
A week?
Not right now.
Not at all,
but uh,
but you say vodka sodas.
Yeah,
but people's,
even if I,
if I go on stage,
I want to on stage one time affiliate,
I didn't feel well and I just bought a
soda water on stage and everyone was
like,
kill it.
And I was like,
there's nothing in it.
And then they're like,
oh really?
And you're like,
yeah.
They're like,
oh,
we thought you were hammered.
And you're like,
no,
I'm just struggling.
I don't like going on stage drunk.
Personally,
I don't like being drunk on stage.
I like,
I like standup comedy.
That's what I got into.
But it's also a part of my personality
is everything is a joke.
I want people to be entertained.
Like this whole weight loss thing.
Supposed to be fun.
I want people to get a kick out of it.
I,
I could definitely have stopped drinking
and been a bore and just been like,
oh,
I think I could.
I could definitely take him.
But I like the fun of juice going,
fuck it.
I'm going to the wall.
But how many days a week do you think
you drink are definitely three.
That just it.
So you drove up saying definitely three.
So you drink less than you don't drink?
No,
I probably drink more than I don't
drink.
That's not three.
What?
This feels like an intervention.
The just curious.
Probably.
I remember when we were the closest of
friends.
I remember he's
were a good father and loved seeing you.
Playing with your children.
Let's,
let's,
let's take a look at this week.
Uh,
attract New Year's Eve.
But I wanted to,
I only had two drinks and I spent the
night in a hotel.
I didn't want to drive home because I
thought the roads would be crazy.
So I received.
Didn't drink yesterday at the rams game.
Didn't drink today.
I'll drink tomorrow and then I get on a
plane to New Jersey on the stress
factory.
I'll drink there.
So maybe maybe I'll drink five of the
seven nights or four.
Seven,
nine,
five.
That's.
But that's an unusual day because you're
cutting back in order to lose weight.
But if I'm home with the girls,
I don't know.
There's no reason for me to drink like
I'm home.
I like a good night's sleep.
I like waking up and being active.
I like going ice skating with them.
I want to do a podcast,
you know?
A lot of times people come on my podcast
and be like,
I want to do a shot with the machine.
And you're like,
I'll never not let them have that.
So of course,
and I count that as a drinking day,
but I'll have one shot but that wouldn't
affect me.
That doesn't.
I'm to know and I'm different.
So like how often do you think that.
No different.
No different thing.
I like,
I'm different than everybody.
Doesn't everyone thinks they're fucking
different?
I definitely don't.
You don't know by the way.
Hey,
by the way,
let me,
I hate to be the one to tell you this.
You're the most different human being
that any of us fucking know.
And there you go and I'm not even
different.
So there you go.
Are you going to sit here and let joe
tell us,
how many podcasts do you do week?
How much?
How much working out,
how much standard activity.
Right.
You're amazing.
Everyone says,
how does Rogan do it?
And I just got these different.
You are different than me.
I do it to keep from going crazy,
but it's my mental problem is that have
I don't have things to do.
I'm not happy.
Like I don't.
I just figured out a long time ago in
order to.
For me to be happy,
I have to be exhausted in busy.
I have to be burnt out from working out,
like not burnt out,
but I have to even myself out and I have
to have puzzles.
I've done things to solve.
That's a good thing.
I think being busy makes definitely me
feel better.
You feel like you're getting the worst
feeling is I'm feeling like a lazy bitch
ain't doing shit.
Your level two honestly though.
And he's right among.
Got It is.
It does seem off off the charts like to
do like three,
three,
three hour podcast.
Do Jujitsu.
Do Your bowhunting.
Do fucking Pool B with your favorite
store credit material at the store?
Yeah.
I don't think I've seen you repeat
anything at the store in the fucking
past month.
I've been there like it's off the charts
because I just did a special,
you know,
once I released a special.
Yeah,
me too.
I'm still doing the same shit.
You got to chip away at new stuff and
people get mad at you,
but I'm still in the new stuff.
I'm working on new stuff.
I've seen the brand new stuff every
fucking time you aren't.
Look,
I
got it right.
I don't really like discipline.
Oh,
I do too.
I wrote the other way too.
I feel like you have to write like that.
I think a lot of people,
I mean I don't tell people what to do
because a lot of people don't like to
write this way,
but I feel like this sitting out in
front of a fucking computer with nothing
but writing in my mind it,
it enhances my ability to write on stage
and it gives me tools that I can use to
ad Lib and do it the other way as well.
I think that's true because there's a
thing that people say,
oh,
I write on stage.
Well,
I do too.
Everybody does.
A lot of people write on stage,
but I think you should right in front of
a fucking notebook to have a hard time
with that.
Everybody does.
I do too.
No,
but I mean like,
I mean it doesn't.
It doesn't inspire me creatively to sit.
It's because you got to do it.
It's like a discipline.
No,
I've done it.
I've,
I've definitely done it.
It just does like for me,
if I'm being dead serious,
if I take a walk,
my brain will start working and that's
fine too.
As long as you dedicate specific time to
writing.
I mean if it's just like a walking thing
and then you talk into a microphone,
that to me is it's,
you know,
you can call it writing.
Like if I'm sitting in front of a
computer,
I'm writing in air quotes,
but if you're walking and you talk to
your phone,
you have an idea and you record it.
That's writing to just creativity.
I do that,
but you have to have my,
my thinking is the more time you spend
forcing yourself to like right now is
that the desperate times because my
specialist just released and I'm doing,
you know,
uh,
did new years and I'm doing these big
shows and I'm doing an hour and I got a
new fucking shit and some of it is
unlike colt legs.
Some of my new materials look
like some of it's alive,
some of it's killing,
some of it's like new stuff that's doing
really well and other stuff is like,
every time I do it was like,
is it going to work tonight,
am I going to find a new way to do it,
am I going to.
And then sometimes out of nowhere I'm
just taking a chance and I'm going the
wrong way.
I take a chance and I start talking to,
I'll,
I'll do the punchline first or I'll do
this part.
You know,
the,
the strongest part of it leading into
the weakest part of it.
Like for no reason,
I just,
I just take this crazy chance to try it
and I know while I'm doing it I'm like,
fuck yeah,
going can dig yourself out of this hole.
But that's what gets you through it.
Well,
the only thing that gets you through it
as like a lot of sense,
you've just got to keep hammering sets
and then every mistake you make from
that,
you applied to the next set and then six
months down the line you have a real
hour that you could put in a special.
No wait,
let's talk about that real quickly
because a,
I agree with you.
I think.
I think you got to be on stage and be
doing it.
Like that's why I love weekends,
uh,
clubs because you got six sets in there,
the best and you're like,
I got it.
I've said that to my,
my manager recently.
I'm like,
what I want to do?
Like they're like,
they want to book me because I can sell
off these big ass places.
Now I'm like,
I want to do clubs,
I want to do more clubs.
Like,
right.
Especially right.
Right now I'm going to do four shows in
a weekend.
You know,
I want to do shows.
That's the way to do it,
man.
Those four shows in a 200 seat room.
That's where it's at.
But let's talk timeline with both of you
guys because I think you've done what,
three hours now?
I've recorded four,
so I'm working on my fifth.
But do you think six months is too quick
to turn around an hour or for
production?
Yes.
No,
no,
I meant I meant meaning for you.
Writing was because like right now I
have a new hour,
but I go.
I don't know.
I feel like I want it to breathe.
I want it eight months and see how it
is.
That's what I let it grow because I
don't know what you guys do on
Wednesday.
You guys around on Wednesday have
flooded in New Jersey.
What are you doing?
I'm going to do the ice house if you're
around.
Yeah.
What is it?
10 Wednesday you,
me and Ron White.
Holla.
Holla at your boy.
Oh Shit.
Bitches.
Fuck.
I'll see you guys.
Stress factory fact.
Kansas City this weekend.
Oh,
when do you leave?
Thursday I'm doing helium.
No,
Kansas City.
That's in St Louis.
I thought they have an alien.
Begins during the Improv.
Improv.
Improv,
Kansas City.
I'm doing the Wilbur January 21st.
So if you'd like to come see me in a
theater,
which is very seldom I don't.
I'm not a big theater guy because I
don't think my act translate archway to
sell tickets.
Burt,
will the Wilbur's the best theater ever.
That's what everyone says.
Super Shallow.
Oh really?
There's three stacks.
It's like having three comedy clubs
stacked on top of each other.
It's amazing.
The Wilbur in Boston is fucking amazing.
Go get tickets guys.
January 21st.
I'll be there.
That's a good spot.
All right,
let's wrap this bitch up.
Um,
so tomorrow,
11:00 in the morning,
going to find out.
Is it going to be the water champ or is
it going to be the machine?
The machinist machinist.
So tune in tomorrow.
Hashtag who is fat week?
Do we take the beer right away?
Oh fuck you.
Starting it off.
And then we party.
Well,
I'm going to bring in if I purchased a
electric shaver,
so I'm bringing a brand new electric
shaver.
We'll pop it out so nobody has to worry
about aids.
Like trimmers.
Yeah,
put the clipper thing.
I
ordered.
I ordered a barber's Cape,
so.
Oh,
beautiful.
Do you have a sponsorship for Dollar
Shave Club?
Dollar Shave Club's my sponsor.
It's on sponsors the podcast,
but we'll give them a free one.
I've always wanted to use their razors.
I fucking Greg and going to the race,
right.
Submitted stuff called Dr. Carver's easy
shave butter.
Have you ever used that to?
I've never obviously had been 12 years.
Oh,
that's right.
You haven't.
What about your balls?
No.
Uh,
you know what?
I got so fat.
It was a lot of guesswork.
So I stopped.
And on that note,
Ladies and Gentlemen,
Tomorrow 11 am Pacific.
We will see you.
Bye.
Love you.
One
of the best podcasts I've ever been.